[Music]
this one didn't win anything to all of
them was this one this is a different
wendy remix
this one's really good
maybe a runner up this one would tear
the this one would tear a club down bro
to all of them hey
hey we're my people in the back of them
to all of them and then
[Applause]
if we could get the isis remix in there
that would really pop off
i'd love to hear uh you know what i want
is a windy death to all them isis
dubstep remix
someone out there make that brutal
you be fire
well my friends here we are
it is tuesday actually um
because me and ela took a trip to new
york this weekend for our anniversary
um so welcome everybody hope you had a
good weekend
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and raycon we love love love you
if you guys want to call in you know
it's 808 hot meme
call in share your stories share your
thoughts
tell me whatever you want
and we'll
try to get to you
um how's everyone weekend
very good long weekend eh yeah nice went
to joshua trees really nice
wait i thought you went to palm springs
we both aren't they are they opposite
directions
i i'm not sure honestly i just put in
the gps and go i think they're it's like
20 minutes away from each other
not really yeah what'd you think of palm
springs it was nice it was really nice
um we didn't really plan anything i wish
we did it ahead of time but i was really
cool she said sitting in the middle of
the desert i'm not really sure what to
plan there i mean it's just exactly i
haven't been there in a while but i just
remember it's like
city in the middle desert
by the way this is cool did we get these
raided
were we
no
unfortunately no i want to get them
certified
and rated
we could look into i'm not sure if sam's
not down here right now but i think she
may have looked into it yeah i want to
send them in do they not accept random
cards or does it need to be like pokemon
i think they may not accept random cards
oh come on i want a rating well these
are mint i can tell you that
so
you know i don't know if i mentioned but
i made a tick tock of these and tick
tock immediately took it down
can't talk about james it's crazy i mean
of all the tick tocks that go up and all
this crap i've seen on tick tock
it is definitely the james charles thing
and it was down like a minute flat
i mean did they not get the memo on
james
oh my god this is the t
sister sniped by the way speaking of
james new merch just dropped
i mean who first of all who's going to
be walking around in sister merch like
i'd rather just put on my my bill cosby
jello merch
at this point it's like what the [ __ ]
bro
looks kind of nice though actually i'm
not going to hate on it
nice little sherpa a little sister stamp
um it should just have his at snapchat
address what's his snapchat
i'll look into that
that'd be fire just follow me on at
snapchat
didn't get that many likes though so it
is a little bit encouraging i guess it
only got 1500 likes
you know what i mean
it's socks
let's see it's just at james charles
yeah there you go
that's kind of a weird
that looks weird as [ __ ] how they like
cut out the sherpa
to letters so
embarrassing
let's see
i'm curious how much of this [ __ ] is
selling
oh that's 70 dollars for that that's got
to be really bad quality
because a nice sherpa jacket like that
is going to run you like at least a buck
50.
i would think
i don't know that you can make that for
man i'd love to get my hands on one of
these just but anyway all the sizes are
there so
okay that's good you know that is
encouraging
what do you think of the names
vanilla latte
caramel frappuccino
pumpkin spice cold brew and black coffee
i mean it's got a theme
i don't know what to say it's got a
theme does that make sister sense the
grand the grande style
it's chic cafe chic it's a vibe
uh
i don't know
well which color would you get let's say
let's just the black is generally the
most popular style
and uh we have all sizes that's great i
mean that is encouraging because
this man
is a danger to society
and i'd hate to see yeah so it doesn't
seem like it's doing that good so that's
kind of interesting hey guys
not here to tap dance on his grave or
anything but
this is good
because i feel like traditionally this
would have sold out before all the
controversy right like his sister hoodie
that he stole from teddy fresh that that
[ __ ] moved quick right yeah yeah that
moved quick oh you know what else
i'm gonna let me check out his tic talk
because usually he has like these
massive influencers pumping up his about
to say is larae uh rocking this sherpa i
doubt it open tells me he's not
let's see usually he james charles
his tick tock is funny
it's fun
yeah look look who he has modeling it
whenever you open it i'll send you it
i'm opening it right now let's see oh
he's got all of them on let's go
wait wait wait okay
let's sell some sherpas i'm wearing all
of them
oh man he's down bad dude the five other
models canceled
exactly it's just him now
yeah i remember he had such a massive uh
he had such a massive campaign around
the teddy fresh hoodie
but this one only has a hundred thousand
views well he just posted it okay
all right
that's it uh just this one
i believe so yeah that's all i'm saying
okay
sister snatched
um
yeah the weekend was nice you know we
ran into a lot of people it was nice i i
really go outside so we got to meet
uh
meet a lot of fans out there that was
fun
had some nice meals
and uh [ __ ] hate traveling though you
guys i just don't know
and i miss the dogs and the baby
and the flying is just
you guys feel the same way like i feel
like it's almost not even worth it
i know i've often wondered what's the
deal with airplane food am i right
i have wondered that
what's the deal with airplane food
where did they make this stuff
actually the food was quite doo-doo
that got a uh
i got a literal brick of meat
and it was cold in the middle it was
frozen in the middle hot on the sides oh
yeah i was like that's fire
then i pooped my pants
uh speaking of uh the quartering just
from the top of the show we got all
kinds of hot new vibes we got it uh we
had the the wendy remix now we've got
the peat in my basement remix this is of
course dedicated to the quartering
he's poking something up he knows
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's intense
that's like a dirty heavy dub right
there boy
of course is a massive fan
[Music]
let's go baby
[Music]
[Applause]
i got robbed
that was the buildup of no drop
shout out to w uh ckd music wicked
um
interesting
come on don't be a hater give it up
jeremy it was funny come on yeah
okay
wait there's a new r kelly recruiting
song no way so i
let's watch it i think we i think we did
hit this but like three years ago around
the time that we originally discovered r
kelly so it's been a long time no way r
kelly recruiting 18 year old girl to
play
house during concert
who's out there
i got a spare dungeon for you girl come
home
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yo they got props that's what i'm saying
like he pre-meditates this [ __ ] oh yeah
you would think we're going back to the
improvised versus planned debate
this [ __ ] got props you think he
goes all the way all the way up to
ethiopia and doesn't have a slam plan
for recruiting i i agree that the the uh
interlude to recruit young women is
likely planned in the set i just thought
that the the music itself was being
improved no way man this guy brings
props with him
he's like the character predators
[Music]
[Music]
musicians get away with anything bro at
least they used to buy more money more
do you have your passports oh we had a
great idea i don't know if i should
break the
i think i should say it
oh no i don't want it to be a surprise
ian you think we can make it happen i
think we yeah i think we should wait oh
yeah yeah no
[Music]
i'm just so excited yeah we're gonna be
we're working on a holiday miracle yeah
it'll be a holiday miracle in a few
months it's a ways off well yeah let's
definitely save it okay we're gonna get
our kelly out for christmas we're
getting him we're getting him out of
jail everybody
he's gonna be singing a recruitment song
here on the agency podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm surprised there hasn't been more of
a reckoning for the um
james
no
just going off what you were saying
about musicians getting away with
everything there are well you you read
those guys by out by uh biographies and
these guys like they would literally
[ __ ] like
ten thousand women because you know that
all those ten thousand wasn't on the up
and up is it is it uh
uh what's his name from aerosmith
stephen tyler yeah he do you know about
his whole story no he like had like a 14
year old groupie or something that god
that he legally adopted oh god so that
he could like turn her around
stop right [ __ ] now
a 14 year old groupie i i have i might
have the age but it was really 16 year
old groupie dated her and got her
pregnant he adopted her though yeah he
like
guardians because he so that he could
[ __ ] his own daughter
well i don't think that was the strategy
it was what it was i mean dated her for
three years while he was her guardian so
yeah let me get this if he adopted her
when they break up what happens does she
stop being his daughter
well i don't think maybe adopt is the
wrong word he got guardianship whatever
that means he like convinced
the parents
to sign over guardianship to him so that
he could take her oh my god i think so
that he could like take her on tour and
like across state lines because
otherwise that would be like i guess sex
trafficking it'd be child sex
trafficking right
imagine that conversation listen guys uh
me and your daughter were in love
the problem is that uh technically uh if
i were to take her on tour
it would be considered by the fbi as
child sex trafficking now i just want to
make very clear to you
that that's not the case
where's your daddy
yeah
and he's not the only one i'm sure i
think there's tons of stories like that
like groupies and stuff from all those
bands so
wow yeah now gene simmons has been with
over 5000 women so i'm sure
that's what i'm saying it's like just
yeah you you t if you [ __ ] 5 000 women
there's gonna be a lot in there that uh
something was not right right probably a
lot of them
it's game of numbers
oh yeah
golly
oh norm mcdonald is resurrected in the
body of tom cruise this is interesting
don't [ __ ] it what
this isn't edited nope
are you sure yes i first looked at it
and i thought it was not me too so when
i necessarily this came across my feed i
thought it was somebody trolling and
they
had found or or they had put the wrong
lower third like it was norm and they
accidentally put tom cruise and that was
the joke and then
yeah no
no [ __ ] way dude
the title is norm mcdonald faked his own
death to murder tom cruise and assume
his life
there's no way this is not edited
there's more pictures he i need more
pictures here from another angle
here
oh man
well that doesn't look like norm but man
he's kind of falling on
hard times there
yeah i kind of wonder if he's how old is
he
he's pretty old but he didn't look like
that just even like a year or two ago
it's possible just caught up with him
because he's aged so uh well he's 59. oh
my goodness so so
i think he's just looking his age
finally he's so bloated
yeah he's got a chubby face what does
that mean when your face is chubby well
you see that's what i was gonna say is
uh
it it might be that there's something
going on with him he might not be well
usually swelling like that is a sign of
a heart condition i'd like to see using
something like that somebody what is the
symptom because i think that's why i
think that's why norm looked that way
and we know that we now know that he was
not well i always thought norm looked
fine i thought he looked good
no he looked very puffy in the face just
like that
hmm
so wait what does puffy face mean
somebody i mean i'm there's nothing
there's multiple things that could be
linked to them this article specifically
about tom cruise i'm reading thyroid
stuff
sounds like the first line whatever
makes his face blow up between movies is
certainly not scientology
thank you thank you for that little quip
apparently will smith assumed the
identity of uncle phil
[Applause]
yeah this was strange to me when i first
saw this
why did you have to do uncle phil like
that with this pic
how come you don't want me man
why are you quick on that
wow that's crazy everybody in the uh
chat saying cocaine i don't cocaine
makes your face puffy well it can't shut
up with you everybody's saying coke
bloat i mean
that's a thing yeah i mean tom cruise
definitely got that energy steroids
steroids seems
the most likely out of those because
he's still doing like action movie kind
of yeah because i bet you he's still in
good shape you know
he just got that
coke blob
maybe he fell too hard from some of his
stunts mission he's got that mission
impossible look
bro that that's that
that's that
mission floatable
yeah it's loadable it seems no one knows
for sure but there's a lot of causes for
puffy face injuries allergic reactions
infections
yeah
um
okay i'm watching alcohol kidney oh my
god we got so many i don't got so many
doctors in the chat right now fillers
alcohol yeah i know alcohol says that
but i don't think tom cruise recent
photo let's see if we can get a battery
battery i said oh god there's oh old tom
is getting the puffy face treatment guys
man that's got to feel bad
you know
but he's 59 i mean the guys looks good
for 50. absolutely
he's still a stud you know not hating on
him but something my aunt pointed out a
long time ago he has a tooth directly in
the middle of his mouth yeah really yeah
it's not aligned it's offset
very nice smile but interesting a little
off
also a short king tom cruise oh my god i
push back and it goes to each photo like
are you [ __ ] me in the tits page six
nobody
is that's not what anyone meant with the
back button
that's so ridiculous
here's a recent one
looks fine to me
maybe he got an allergic reaction to a
[ __ ] peanut
he looks great here
you know
looks
phenomenal he had one puffy fuss
one puffy face day and the whole world
got a riot oh that looks like a bump in
his throat you need to get that checked
out
could be adam's apple
anyway who cares good luck good luck i'm
sure i'm sure the wizards at scientology
are
all over that
working hard
yo smash mouth had
[Music]
such an epic weekend
smash mouth of shrek fame
i always like i think about them the
kind of rock and roll that was around
during that time and i've i've always
thought like the best dub because you
have like the spin doctor smash mouth
and then there was another one like the
fast tuckers the chicken chick chick and
the choco suckers sugar rain
bare naked ladies sure naked ladies okay
yeah sugar ray it's a little sugary
similar vibes to smell but anyway the
name the genre i like to call it is
shrek raw yes do you like that you've
explained it many times i have not yes
you have
maybe it's a good idea dan you're mad
ogre rock what do you think shrek rock
or swamp brock
swamp rock's already a thing that's
already like
wait what is swamp rock like southern
swampy style
oh
like uh so shrek rock it is leonard
skinner no
[Music]
are you sure zach yes
i've heard of swamp rock before i've
seen swamp pop what is swamp rock
everything come out of florida swamp
swamp rock
yeah well [ __ ] me
it's a mix uh country funk and soul i
know that sounds good i'm seeing one
band that's part of swamp rock you
[ __ ] you know what it is zach don't
you clayton's clean water
yes sir
what was i saw somebody in the chat
earlier oh is the the the the kavanagh
keemstar revival or something
that's funny that that one a lot of it
well ryan kevin is not that far off from
teaming up with kim i mean that guy is
so close to bankruptcy at this point
we'll get into that i'm jumping ahead of
myself but
i like shrek rock and um
man
shrek kind of killed this man's career
and life
he was too successful in shrek and
people just associated one with shrek
you know
it's hard to prove about four however
what about four
but for a shrek a butt for
you missed an opportunity dude
so funny no i've not heard anyone say
that other anyways what's a butt [ __ ] i
can't jerk off to this
[Laughter]
anyways i think that their career was
already uh diminished significantly and
shrek was it was a second revival so do
you think shrek brought him out of the
swamp
exactly well
smash mouth was in like every movie
around that time there was a ben stiller
movie
yeah mystery men right there was uh race
it was in rat race as well right it was
like 99 right that's when they were but
i was so down with that [ __ ] back in the
day
it's like oh [ __ ]
so the first shrek film came out in 2001
i believe all star was from 1999 so it
was only two years later hey now you're
a swamp star get your game on that song
sucks but like looking back it's so bad
but it's so [ __ ] cool too you gotta
admit it's catchy oh i love that song
it's annoyingly catchy yeah it's
horrible but it's great
i think the bare naked ladies had the
same [ __ ] what was their hut song it's
been thought
like fast talking catchy
actually i still listen to the very
native ladies i think they're a great
band like
unironically
they have a pretty dedicated follow-up
so so so in the shrek rock competition
barenaked ladies took the w
they they take that big old dub they're
the greatest rock band of all time yeah
they took that big dub well you also
consider hallelujah a shrek song would
you consider that shrek rock what you've
said you've said before no it's not
you've sang song you've said because
it's in the movie it's not shrek raw
because it's in the movie i've never
said that you still put words in my
mouth no i i remember
vividly well i'll say it right
hallelujah is not shrek rock okay i'm
just
that's just a clown that's a beautiful
classic song you can't uh categorize
that i agree
also talking about the same hallelujah
yeah yeah i don't know what zack's all
about
shrek yeah yeah it is
soundtrack
all-star was in several movies at the
time including digimon
how do you use the same song in several
movies always been 10 weeks since you
sniffed my butt
come around you know i got a hot one
take a drink
sarah in our chat saw bare naked ladies
in vegas uh this weekend oh so see
there's
the bear naked ladies dubs i got some
fans out there great ben dubs all around
well anyway speaking of smash mouth
uh
you see she did
smoush math
hey now
all star and of course shrek is love
shrek is alive
so she knows
anyway she went and saw smash mouth in
concert
and what has become one of the most
disastrous live shows ever recorded that
has led ultimately to him in response to
this going viral retiring
somehow this out did their performance
last year at sturges which i think
caused like a quarter million covet
infections or something i was telling
somehow this is worse i was telling dan
they got the sturgis curse now yes
exactly
yeah everyone who went to surges is
cursed many of them are dead actually
nobody knows why assassinated
by hillary clinton
yeah exactly
nobody knows why
well anyway here is a recap of a smash
mouth show and boy this is a great one
okay i know the ethics of this aren't
great but i did just see smash bath
perform live at a local beer and wine
festival
when i say this is the most chaotic show
i've ever seen in my entire life
i have no words at no point was the
sound balance
unintelligible speech
a straight up pile
a zig heil
[Music]
he's not even trying
[Music]
the problem is he wants to be a rock he
wants to be a rock star but it's like
can can you be a rock star when your
claim to fame is hey now
that's not right i mean it's one of the
highest selling singles of maybe not
1990s maybe not a rock star but maybe an
all-star
oh like can you smash a guitar to all to
hey now i mean if you really tried
hey now you're an awesome maybe maybe
until maybe they're walking on the sun
that's that's a great song that is a
good i don't even know that song you do
danny d
go ahead
sing it
i got nothing
keep going
give me some to sing some tunes
see you um
didn't even know the song exactly i do i
was
[Music]
as well be walking i told you
all you need to hear was like a split
second of it yeah it's not okay okay
it's another big hit this it's almost 60
million views on youtube this song
okay
and you could for sure smash a guitar
that's all i don't think so no not
really at all
well
anyway there was a follow-up from her
apparently the show was so bad
that
here is them analyzing did he do a zig
heil it sure looked like it to me
isn't that what it's called
yeah i'm sure
what it's it i don't think it's zig it's
like sig well in german s is a z so
maybe i'm just too literate for you i'm
an anti-semitic
person oh keemstar come on that you
don't need to interject that
i mean inappropriate it's just it's
hurtful when you say that's not what i
think it is what else what then you can
see this guy turn around and say
did you see that
um and um
and yeah he does do it again
was like that's not what i think i mean
what is that
i think it's a nazi salute yeah i mean
straight up i'm not sure how else to
and he does it with a lot of gusto too
like he's not pointing
he's not doing much but that's just a
straight heil my dudes
here is shrek rock um
personified
that is shrek
as the rock ladies and gentlemen we have
done it we have gone all the way there
we have achieved science has gone to
maximum potential
shut up [ __ ] okay calm down this is my
swamp [ __ ]
oh this was submitted by melvin dew on
discord by the way the smash mouth saga
so thank you well it's become quite the
story and as you'll see there's
so the fallout yeah here's some fallout
smash mouth steve uh harwell retires
citing physical and mental health issues
i'm sorry buddy
smashed his mouth is smashed
you
uh announced his retirement following
the uproar over a cons uh concert one
attendee described as the most chaotic
show i've ever seen in my life yeah we
know who that attendant is la times how
about some
siding
that girl literally ruined his career i
think she single-handedly made him
retire
yeah well i mean if he's in this state
it was bound to happen
uh sooner than later you know
it says in this article that he says he
has some neurological disorder and
severe alcoholism so uh
despite his best take a break he is
heartbroken to share that it has become
impossible for him to continue doing
what he loves most
uh playing all-stars endlessly getting
drunk and playing all-star
i've tried so hard to power through my
physical mental health issues and to
play in front of you one last time but i
wasn't able to
oh
damn
the world was robbed this day so many
chad said she saved his life yeah could
be actually ah that's a that's a really
optimistic positive way to spend it and
it might be true you know yep
although i have to say being publicly
shamed this way probably
not not the best way to uh
i don't blame her though i mean i love
the video what can you do
uh if while during the show harwell
threatened audience members he said i'll
[ __ ] kill your whole family i swear
to god he told one fan
while giving what appeared to be a nazi
salute to the crowd
so rock and roll
that is kind of rock and roll so rock
and roll
oh so we're working on a thumbnail for
the video guys yeah what do you think
does that look real it doesn't look like
i'm pointing to her is there a way to
work on the angle
wait this isn't real
sorry
right good point no this is a candid
photo it was real but can you just edit
it to make it make it look more like i'm
pointing at her cam in this candid photo
from new york
thank you
thank you
we bought the or no no
we took that photo we took that photo
what the [ __ ] does she know about
cameras
i don't
i don't know kanye i don't know what she
knows about cameras
the spokesman for the group said he has
suffered uh proof bruce lee over the
years
yada yada yada
regarding the apparent nazi salute they
said that the singer regrets his actions
but this tick-tock video is not an
accurate representation of the man steve
is oh so they don't deny it
it sounds like they're saying he was
having an episode
that's you know
there okay
man these these never get easy that he
sure don't
his contemporary uh uh
sugar ray is heartbroken steve is gonna
wind up on cameo any day now i'm
surprised he's not
off the charts and then what would his
thing be out of the swamp and into your
home
in your hearts
oh
man
remember that all that glitters is gold
all that glitters is good
only shooting stars do the nazi salute
we went from all-star to keemstar
[Applause]
zach
zach with the i'm gonna applaud myself
on exactly
buddy that was good that was good
wow oh
geez
uh before
are you moving on to the next story yeah
it's ad time
baby
alrighty i was just looking there's so
much good stuff today there really is i
mean you could do another if you want
we're not
let's just get through
we got two ads let's bust through them
and let's get to the show we got some
calls i want to get to as well but
before that let's thank honey honey
honey honey honey
we all shop online folks and we've seen
that promo code field taunt us spit in
our face slap us
stomp on our balls
i don't know if that's happened to me
but i mean you know i gotta keep using
it metaphorically dan right you don't
even have to think about it dude
but thanks to honey manual searching for
coupon codes as a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for from i almost
said porno codes
i mean it's so good at scraping codes it
may it may
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart and honey supports over 30 000
stores online
ranging from tech
gaming
fashion
food delivery
here's how it works
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click apply codes wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons it
can find for that site and if honey
finds a coupon code you automatically
for free instantly watch the price drop
it's a no-brainer i mean it takes two
clicks to install it's a it's a browser
extension
and uh you're gonna be surfing with
peace of mind after that i'll tell you
me and ela
save so much money with honey i've been
using it really i don't i i it's one of
my first installs when i get a clean
laptop you know
and
um it's amazing it's like 50 bucks 20
bucks 10 bucks you don't even have to
think about it dude yeah it's a
no-brainer try it out there's a reason
honey has found it's over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings you guys
and if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings literally free installs in a few
seconds and by getting it you're gonna
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast we love you for that nah
i never recommend something i don't use
so please get honey for free at
joinhoney.com h3tv that's joinhoney.com
h3tv thank you thank you peace and love
and finally folks i'd like to give a
shout out to
ray
let's freaking go
dude the raycons pop they slap
it's basically
that classic beautiful bluetooth
headphones that you love
it's got the rechargeable case
they're sleek they're beautiful they're
modern the sound
great
i don't think that's how you put them on
there dan i think you're wearing
headphones
yeah look at that
slick but the i mean it's fantastic it's
it it is a great product whether using
it to pump up lying down work or work
out raycons are the go-to
for the go-to audio and the new everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever we've got an improved rubber oil
look and feel it's soft it glides right
into your ear like butter baby
the optimized gel tips are the perfect
in-ear fit they're impressive before you
even start listening but wait till you
turn the audio on you get three new
sound profiles and make sure you're
listening to the sounds with the best
just a right amount of bass you've got
pure mode for listening to podcasts
blues instrumentals balanced mode for
podcasts listening uh a rock heavy rock
metal and bass mode for hip-hop edm and
reggae
there's also an all-new awareness mode
for when you need to listen to your
surrounding sounds raycon offers eight
hours of playtime with a 32 hour battery
life there's also a built-in mic so you
can take calls on your earbuds at the
press of a button raycon starts at just
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good and
if you don't believe it
that's why they come with a 45-day
happiness guarantee yep
right now for h3 podcast listeners you
can get 15 percent off the raikon order
at buy raycon.com h3 that's by raycon
dot com slash h3 to save 15
on ray cons by raykun.com
h3 thank you thank you peace and love
this is a serious message
let's take some calls here oh man we
missed
oh maybe we didn't
went to school with the famous tick
talker
i see one who's jared stodd stoddard
stott hill
um that sounds vaguely familiar
they have screenshots provided of him
paying someone to send him hate online
no way
but let's pull up a picture i want to
see if i even tic talk is our home
absolutely
jared this the name sounds familiar
this isn't this is a real expose right
here
there's an there's a few exposes in here
with proof provided i'm asking for
one right now wait what's this [ __ ]
guys jared
stoddengale
stark
here we go
do you guys recognize this guy
i
what
i'm it's not even tick tock stuff
wait jared somebody help me out put
put up some [ __ ] photos
oh i'm looking for the call that you're
referencing from the bottom
stod jarrett this is him
this guy's not famous what's famous
about this guy
i don't even see his tick tocks
never uh
not familiar with this person
uh
okay
he has eight million followers why is he
not showing up oh
there's some rest who doesn't want to
all right some somebody help me out here
million is like
true it could be a that's nothing okay
hear it that's nothing let's see here he
is
eight million
views are kind of low for eight million
oh this one is thirty million oh he's
got walking people
i feel like a lot of people are going to
stare at me but let
the music so he's got one eye he's got a
false eye
he's going to walk around in public
with a terminator eye
i mean why not have fun with it
whoa
that's pretty crazy it's cool
yeah i'm reading that a lot of his
videos
are like this
hasta la vista i don't see any he's not
doing anything bad i mean i'll talk to
this guy but let's let's proceed
cautiously because
this guy didn't seem to be doing
anything wrong but obviously based on
this one video i've seen hannah what's
what's your beef with um
jarrett
okay so um first of all i just want to
say i'm a huge fan thank you so much i
love you um
i'm from actually funny story i actually
i'm from people i'm not from but i live
in cedar rapids
like the hillary clinton meeting
let's go
actually
um but i'm actually from a small town so
like i'm from iowa so
uh for example i literally graduated
with like 21 people in my class i think
wow so
very very small cedar rapids thank you
zach
yes thank you zach love you anyways um
so
uh jared sachel he went to a school near
me
um actually a guy i was dating at the
time was like in the same weight class
as him and so they would wrestle like
in like you know tournaments and stuff
so this guy
has been so i i think he i'm pretty sure
he is in the same grade as me i
graduated in 2018 i might be wrong don't
don't i'm not sure on that but uh he
has had i think five twitter accounts
that have all gotten suspended for what
um because he just he steals people's
tweets
they don't say they don't suspend
i think you have to actually want to
kill a minority or something to get
suspended on twitter okay
all right and also i sent the
screenshots to olivia i don't know if
she can
if you guys can pull those up so you
know
yeah but how did you get these
screenshots you'd even go to high school
with them you don't know him personally
why are you trying to expose him i'm
friends with i'm friends with him on
facebook like i know this guy so why are
you doing this
because i just wanna okay so let me
explain okay so this guy he did have
cancer like when he was i think he said
he was a baby and they had gotten the
eye removed whatever okay yeah i feel
bad for him i really do like i'm just
like and speaking truthfully like i know
what it's like my mom passed away in
like january this year like i know like
i would never
specifically do something to like be
mean about somebody's illness like i
just want to make that very clear okay
um
but this guy i sent the proof to olivia
on discord
um
so he
the top picture is hard to see it's a
side profile picture of him shirtless
and the second photograph is wait how
did you get messaging how did you obtain
these
if you look on twitter like and go to
his old twitter accounts like i said the
last like four or five have gotten
suspended because he just steals
people's content
so someone posted these um
yeah they're not that hard to find and
also like this was when i was in high
school and this happened it was like
wait this was a public comment this is a
public comment because it has likes on
it say look at the camera and quit
trying to show off your jawline or
something like that and fyi you're going
to get a lot of hate like a lot of hate
but why is it a public comment with
likes oh it's just a screenshot i see
i think i know what he's trying to do
he's looking for a perfect comment that
he can do at
you know what i mean yeah okay so so the
thing is
his twitter like like i said the first
picture you can't see it but like you
can see he's like collarbone it's a
shirtless photo of him and he's like
facing the side and so he said like
message me and like say you know why are
you always look have your face to the
side
he was like he paid this guy to send a
message
publicly on twitter and then he says
okay and then he gets to be the good guy
he goes everyone stop hating on the guy
he didn't know and he apologized for it
there is so much hate in this world and
no one deserves to be made fun of legend
thank you all for caring and supporting
me it means the world to me by the way
at least he was like um
i will say at least he was like you're
going to get a lot of hate for this so
he was kind of like
upfront about that yeah i mean
yeah and it was just some guy that he
knew like that was following him on
twitter so the guy sent a public you
know like reply to the tweet saying like
why are you always looking to the side
and then he
tweeted that you know he got
a lot of hate like he said he was gonna
get and he you know deleted it right
away because he was getting so much hate
and then the second photo that i sent to
olivia um it says since the guy deleted
the tweet did you get that picture yeah
he says since the guy deleted the tweet
did someone want to post the same thing
on the side so i can redo it for clout
but i hate to break it to you
um
if you think this is bad you should hear
what james charles did
oh no i'm very well aware i mean
listen
i mean it's it's a little scummy but uh
he's 22. he's trying to get on that
cloud game i mean it's a little it's
dude yeah i mean yeah he's trying to get
that clown pill
yeah he's
what's going on with you and jared what
happened i don't
i literally do not hate this guy i will
i'm saying i
no i really don't but i literally i
wanted you to watch like his tick tock
because i just think they are really
cringy
and like so
i mean it's all about his eye i don't
see him doing anything like overtly that
was only one but i mean the terminator i
was cool they're all i mean they're all
about here's one with 7 million
yeah
they're just so like acted out the one
where he's in the gym and he's like
trying to get people's reactions so it's
just a guy
is this the guy who bought all of his
followers and like has always been
feeling tweets like like i said he's
been doing this since high school he
wasn't like vendetta she's a hater she's
got an i think we've got a hater on
people
wait let me let me ask you a question
hannah but i'm just okay there's there
are people who like like i'm i feel i
get it he really does have cancer and he
really did like but he's paying someone
to bully him
when there's people who like actually
get bullied like you know what i'm
saying right hannah
i mean it is i feel like you
you say you guys came from the same
small town is he the guy that like made
it out no
you see you see where like i said
huh
i think you're a hater hannah
i really am not a hater with peace and
love like i'm
i just wanted to like get your reaction
to this guy really i just wanted to see
what you had to say i mean i've seen so
much worse i i agree it's it's
interesting he was giving me very like
jake paul logan paul crin
and now he's got like some it's all i
mean it's just i memes he's not he's
just riding the eye thing all the way up
he's just riding the i mean man
like there's nothing else yeah but it's
like he's but he paid someone money to
bullying i agree i don't know i
it's scummy it's funny
um it's embarrassing obviously for him
but like it pales in comparison to the
[ __ ] like we see in flinches doing today
which is like theft scamming
predatory behavior i mean
david dobrik literally [ __ ] ran over
his friend with an excavator bro
like yeah the bar is so high these days
you know
true yeah i'm just saying like this that
these people these people are getting
big by doing shitty things and
from small towns who are trying to get
big they're also doing these shitty
things because they think hannah i got a
question i mean i don't how much did
jarrett pay you to call in and bully him
like this he did not pay me
no
i never heard of this guy jared
i never heard of this guy jared now all
of a sudden we're talking all about him
we're talking all this trash about this
poor guy with one eye
i need that clout
yeah no i knew him from like i said we
went to
he went to a school near me and a guy i
dated used to wrestle him
who won the wrestling match your
boyfriend or jared
uh actually if if you want i have a
video no i just want to know who won
okay well there were multiple times
they've wrestled and he jarrett won like
two times and then i think my
ex-boyfriend won the third time so it's
a bit is this a bitter thing oh
okay no no no it's not interesting
you're bitter that he beat your
boyfriend wrestling
listen hannah no i'm not saying that
anymore we gotta respect the buzzer
hannah i understand first of all it was
a great it was an entertaining call
thank you for bringing it to my
attention jared stoth hill is on my
[ __ ] radar now boy
better not slip up on me
and hannah thank you for watching thank
you for watching i sincerely appreciate
the call thank you
we're just having fun all right all
right take care love you keep watching
thank you we need every viewer
i think she's on jared's payroll
that was a good that was it fits
everything she described
interesting
we have a funny keemstar story went to a
fan meetup as a joke went in teddy fresh
hoodie kim realized after a few photos
photo sent sure i i'll take keemstar
slander any day
we have photos drop those photos olivia
hello to joe
joseph what up what up what up peeps
[Applause]
there you go there you go all right tell
me your story what you got for me
well i was just sitting on my couch
and i was just scrolling through twitter
and i saw that keemstar was having a fan
meet up at
some like crazy dive bar like 10 minutes
away from me and i like live in the
middle of the sticks so i was just like
it was oh yeah it was it was a meet-up
for him and fousey's new brand right
i think that's when he met
the the girl the
the first underage or not sorry not
underage like young like what was with
fuzzy yeah was that a fussy mute up
right [ __ ]
up yeah yeah so dude the bar is only
like 10 minutes away from my house and
like it's like a well-known bar around
us it's like like a joke like it's
it's so funny so then like i saw that he
was there so i'm like oh let me go put
on my my color block hoodie
and go take a picture with keemstar here
i got the photo so i literally i'm going
to show the photo yeah i went there and
like
yeah how tall are you bro you're
powering over his ass
like the thing is i'm only 5 10. like he
must be like no you're 5 10.
you're lying
you're [ __ ] like
okay yeah yeah
you're [ __ ] you're massive bro
yo he's wearing a present
yeah i know he's wearing a full set i
posted that on
i posted that on the subreddit like two
months ago and like all the comments on
it were so cringy they're like oh dude
you outfit him
you you wanted
keemstar oh yeah you did out for him
let's be honest this is you're standing
up
you are staring up very straight though
i i must compliment you on your posture
there joe
never be a beta
so what happened you took the photo he
did he see the hoodie before the photo
or after or what
yeah so so as soon as i walk into the
bar like i said like everyone is like oh
are you here for the fan meet up because
like it's like a it's like a bar like in
the sticks around me so like i just kind
of stood out like a sore thumb sure and
they're like oh it's right outside so as
i'm walking outside keem starts walking
inside to me and i'm like oh baby
and so i'm like hey man can we just get
a quick pick and so he's like yeah sure
no problem let's take a picture
and i like handed it to someone to like
just take our picture and like the guy
couldn't figure it out for the longest
time how to take a picture
and um so as we're just like and people
people are saying to me they're like oh
man nice hoodie
like it's like a joke because they
obviously know who you are and um
keemstar still didn't notice it and like
so we're still we took a couple pictures
and then at one point he was like oh man
i don't know if we can take this picture
right now and i'm like nah man we've
already taken a few pictures we may as
well take a few more
and so you straight outfit him you
scared him
all right he didn't say it
though which was so funny
i want to say something
just for the record joe
i do i love i appreciate this i don't
want to encourage anyone to go uh harass
keemstar in the real world thank you but
joe thanks for sharing no no i didn't
say i didn't i didn't say anything like
out of pocket i know you i know you're a
perfect gentleman i just wanna i'm just
giving that disclaimer for everyone
listening
specifically keemstar who's currently
writing an email to susan
so that i said do not harass keemstar in
the real world but i'm glad you got to
pick with them i'm sure you're a fan of
dramaalert that's why you went there
right i'm curious how many people are
yeah that's exactly why yeah yeah i love
foosie you love lucy you love dramaalert
that's why you went yeah how many people
would you say came to the fam meetup
so i didn't even like go to the whole
part where the fan meetup was but i
ended up i saw that fousey like posted
like a movie about it or something so i
was curious too it looked like there was
a pretty decent amount of people there
but dude they were like all young kids
like that's what i was yeah i was like a
bar seems like a weird place for a
keemstar because he's looking for a girl
he needs to he needs that barrier for
entry right and also they're shooting a
movie he doesn't want a bunch of kids
look like a [ __ ] weirdo yeah he's
he'll be he out there like the
peter piper like
hypnotizing the kids to follow him
and [ __ ]
anyway what's your favorite drama alert
since you're such a big fan yeah what's
your favorite episode jesus i don't
think i've ever seen a joke
all right thank you joe thank you joe
wait wait wait wait i actually have a
quick question
if you don't mind alpha joe has a
question for you dan yeah go for it
shoot
all right so i know this is a huge
stretch but i heard you say that you're
like a huge classic rock fan and then
the other day i heard you say like
you're a huge bob dylan fan is there any
way in 2016 you went to that music
festival in palm springs or india i
forget what the hell it was
oh [ __ ] the call dropped
really yeah
super unfortunate
did you drop him no it's just a it's
just a weird coincidence yeah it's just
a weird one
there wasn't anything bad about that
question was it no okay
no it was just a weird coincidence
anyway i just want to say thank you for
the call zach was there joe if you're
watching zach i went to that uh i was
not
i was
wait 2016
you know my favorite keemstar video is
in all capital he titled it youtube
needs to delete this channel
just because the irony
i love it was he talking about his own
channel jstation
oh yeah yeah well they listen what the
[ __ ] what is this story are you high bro
but anyway thank you joe for sharing i
do want to actually say though on a
serious note that uh
don't
go and
don't go do his fan meetups to bother
him and stuff he you know
he's living his life he's down bad
that is for sure man we love keem he's
an all-star
he's our favorite anti-semite
[Laughter]
um thank you joe appreciate the call
though i really do i'm sorry
um let's see so moving on
wally p is cured
wait i just found out that the photo
that joe sent us was um
photoshopped
um
here's the real one
so
that one's more accurate no laughter
nothing
i mean what's funny about it it's just
keem's physical appearance i wouldn't i
would never laugh at him for that
right he looks good that's just what he
looks like sick ass beard
i love it you know lenses can distort uh
the space quite a bit so i'm not
surprised that that came out a little
scuffed but i'm glad that we could
account for that i love it he looks like
a little plushie you get out of a claw
machine
all right
too much fun here folks
having too much fun out here right let
me clean up my desktop a little bit
while ep has found the cure it's been
too long since we've heard from
24 7.
should we mention a disclaimer ahead of
time do we have to what's the disclaimer
because he's saying this is a cure for
certain things yeah that i mean okay so
here's my disclaimer to youtube um
this is not this is just a guy this
this guy has no medical training
uh that i know of
should we not even show it are we gonna
get the whole video i that's why i don't
know i just thought about that but i
don't i really don't think it'll be a
problem
based on what dan
because we've shown way crazier like
anti-covered people that's true that's
true this this isn't even that bad
this is not
this is not
peer-reviewed research
this has not been posted in the journal
of science
i i don't know how to properly disclaim
it this is just some dude off the
[ __ ] rails in his house don't follow
his advice what can i say
how do i properly disclaim this get the
vaccine wear a mask don't be a [ __ ]
idiot
okay thank you youtube
fuji's i don't know about english
but safety for the bodies corona this is
lehman
this is machine
just put it
in australia
every morning
one glass ticket
afternoon
dinner you have to eat you take one
glass if you have blood pressure if you
have diabetes if you have mental problem
and you have
lose your weight
100 percent you lose this weight if you
will
[Laughter]
slamming just
just so much garlic that's like almost
entirely garlic
wait let me go back because i need to
get the ingredient list
after eat you take one glass if you have
blood pressure if you have diabetes if
you have mental problems
do you have
[Music]
you turn into arnold schwarzenegger for
a second
goes away you want to lose away 100
percent you lose away
100
every morning every morning after
breakfast after the
dinner uh you would take one glass and
in the morning one glass
of garlic
the smell is emanating off a person that
just slams a giant glass of like
smoothie garlic every morning lemon and
smoothie garlic
[Laughter]
i love what he says diabetes machine
like that machine like that yeah one
machine he just says one machine
shout out to wally uh submitted by block
chicken on discord
thank you block chicken love that oh i
love him
has found the cure basically to
everything i don't think he even said
covert though i don't know he made such
a big about that yeah maybe he didn't
even think of it i thought maybe at the
there was another video where i think he
did
maybe
if it cures you know obesity diabetes
obesity mental health
blood pressure
blood pressure
[Laughter]
i would try that if we could do it just
for the show i don't know what fuji is
he keeps saying
i think he says i don't know what it is
in english
well you know what the name is and
everybody in the chat that [ __ ] it's
like a turnip or not a turnip no it's a
little berry thing
with hard skin i've seen it in the
market okay yeah i figured anybody know
the english name for fujio well google
for jill
how do you spell for geo
i don't know google smart they'll
financially figure it out
[Music]
is it a berry
i think so i think it's a geo berry yeah
uh
what the [ __ ] some anime character is
all that comes up
that didn't work let's see fudgie
oh my god this person sharted in a
tanning bed and put it in her purse
sorry
this is this a call it's a call oh no
sharted in a tanning bed and put the
turd in her purse
chat is saying radish by the way
that was a radish
that's what the chats is that what
fajilla i mean it kind of looked like a
radish but it looks like uh like a nut
set kind of skin though right all these
[ __ ] anime characters come up
because all the dragon ball z characters
are named after like vegetables he
doesn't look like a dragon ball
character though kagarot carrot
right you guys want to hear the tanning
bed i'm kind of fascinated by that
let's what's wrong from anonymous you
don't want to give out your name
you why don't you want to give us your
name
i don't want to give out my name um
because i truly am so embarrassed by
this i'm kidding i can imagine i i
i haven't told anyone this is like the
first time i'm actually like saying this
out loud so do you think people might
work out
do you think anyone will recognize your
voice possibly
oh man i hope not every don't worry
about everybody's just going to assume
she's the troll girl because every
female caller that calls it anyone
analyze your voice yet
what was that admittedly i have not
analyzed her i was asking amy and zach
if they've analyzed your voice yet have
you run through the troll through the
system
trust me i would not i would not make up
like some crazy story about your mom
like that girl was a little ridiculous
the chat is already going off it's the
troll
i thought at first it was her but nah i
think okay that's not good everybody
needs to remember analyze the
wavelengths
we're clearing out anonymous uh tanning
bed turd lady
okay well before i wanna or before i
start i just wanted to thank all of you
guys for making my days a little more
entertaining um like others i work from
home and i look forward to listening to
you guys and i know that you probably
hear that all the time but like i just
wanted to let you guys never know i love
you all so much never enough we love you
too but definitely no i think it's
definitely her no i'm playing i'm fine
now i love you too and thank you so much
by the way radish does come out to alpha
jail
there you go
that's a radish so we can make that
right now
do we have tons of radishes
where's shannon is she she should be are
she upstairs or she coming in soon i
don't
i don't know i don't know well somebody
communicate with her let's get some
radishes garlic and lemon juice and
let's all take a shot of life yeah
[ __ ] horrible
i'll uh i'll message her so anyway um uh
sorry anonymous uh tanning bed [ __ ]
oh she's off today my bad yeah i
remember she's off today do we have
anyone available to do that maybe i can
ask alina yeah maybe she has i think
lina's out right now anyway so let me
ask her
lena we need a shitload of garlic
radishes and lemons and a machine and
one machine she's got weirder requests i
think we have a blender here we have one
machine let me go check let me see if we
have a machine that's a machine
okay i'm with you uh tanning bed so what
so let's see what did you eat let's
start from the beginning of the day
well so i was going to you know start
the story by saying that i have ibs i'm
a proud idea survivor
and i always have had poop issues like
throughout my life um but it's super
weird like there are always like there
are like certain situations where i feel
like i need to [ __ ] myself all the time
so like for example whenever i go to
target
or whenever i'm in like the purdue
section of a grocery store
hobby lobby it's just like random places
i think it's because like i
go ahead
i was gonna say you kind of have an uh a
natural state of wanting to [ __ ]
yourself
yeah all the time interesting and do you
and how often does it happen i don't
have to skip myself
how often does it happen yeah um like
every day every day you shoot yourself
every day
oh my goodness i'm sorry
i feel like i feel like i have to [ __ ]
myself like i never have a feeling where
i'm like
oh i need a poop i should go in like the
next 10 minutes it's always like i need
to find a toilet now or else i'm going
to wait i'm really curious about first
of all i'm very sorry that's that sounds
really rough as a condition
but if you're [ __ ] your pants on a
daily basis do you wear a diaper or
something like how do you deal with that
well so i don't i don't [ __ ] myself
every day it's just that i have a
feeling of meeting okay so how often do
you [ __ ] your pants
the last time i did it was last month i
like was driving in my car and i just i
couldn't get to the toilet anytime so my
husband actually had to clean up the car
it was horrible oh that's love though
it's so bad
but he's the best were you wearing a
skirt or something what happened
i was wearing leggings and oh there's no
space for pooping those things boy
and it was like it was like liquidy like
not to get really gross no go ahead
we're all here to learn we're already in
it
let me ask you this coffee and like i
just really had to go can i ask you a
question with all over
yeah when you [ __ ] yourself in leggings
does it like squirt out of the pores
because it's so porous or does it yeah
yeah yeah that's exactly what happened
yeah
that is exactly what happened it was
horrible and do you wear like a
husband
my poor husband had to clean it up it's
like it's just normal he's a good man
he's a good man
he is he is the best do you wear like do
you wear a thong or do you wear like
bigger diaper
all right sorry bigger underwear
i'm sorry i meant bigger underwear not
diaper
i usually i usually wear a thong oh so
there's just no
there is no containment no containment
there was no like i i had to throw out
like the leggings in the
underwear there was no way that i was
going to like put that in the laundry
that's a good man you got there oh
hey honestly i do yeah he's the best he
truly is the best okay so now we've
established we've established the
pattern this is important we're we're
laying important groundwork
um so yeah let's go to the day when this
all happened
so like i said there are certain like
situations where i always feel like i
need to ship myself and so for a while i
was an avid tanner
so i would go into the tanning beds it
was super nice relaxing and listen to
the music
and i always felt like every time i went
to the tanning bed that i would have to
[ __ ] myself
um can you get out can you get out of
the towning bed before the time's up
you can but you're like i'm like
completely naked and like i have all
this lotion on oh okay
you don't want no yeah it's just it's a
lot yeah right so um
so there was this one time
where i was tanning and
i felt like like i had to [ __ ] myself
but i was like just hold it in it's all
good and
my stomach was starting to hurt and so i
just trusted the fart and
unfortunately like i'm not kidding like
a log came out
um and
it was horrible and i was like
immediately i was panicking because what
was the smell like in that little room
uv
rays in a small room do you want to log
a chin burnt smell like burnt skin and
[ __ ] seriously so
i was freaking out obviously um and i
was a member at this like tanning salon
and like i knew the girls that were
working there and so i was just like
mortified and the thing is when you're
in a tanning bed there's like a timer
and i had 15 minutes
so i had like probably 10 minutes to
figure out what the [ __ ] i was gonna do
um so
i
am like freaking out i'm like what do i
do what i do i like i'm obviously not
gonna leave my own [ __ ] in this tanning
bed because they know what room i'm in
so i dig i dig into my purse and i find
some makeup wipes and so i grab my [ __ ]
i like wrap it up in like 10 different
makeup wipes
and i put it back into my purse because
the girls they clean out the garbage can
every single time so i wasn't going to
leave my [ __ ] in there
so the only way i could survive the
situation was if i took my [ __ ] out of
the tanning bed or the tanning stone you
cleaned up
pretty fortunate that it wasn't a wet
one though eh because i don't think you
could have got that cleaned up they call
them no it was just like yeah
thankfully it wasn't like a liquidy one
it was like a log and so then i
bring it to my purse and then it smells
obviously so i have like thankfully i'd
perfume in my bag and so i spray the
room
and once the timer was done i like like
just skirted out of there and i actually
canceled my membership that day like i
called in and i cancelled my membership
because wait you didn't go to the
bathroom you
you didn't go to the bathroom and flush
it
no
i ended up throwing it away at my house
you drove all the way home with that huh
yeah okay you put the windows down at
least absolutely horrible
what was that do you put the windows
down at least
yes and i will say even though the car
ride was only like two minutes long my
car
reeked it was awful
does your husband does your husband know
the story story
what was that does your husband know
this story
i don't know if he knows the story oh
that is deep trauma if you if he's if he
even he doesn't know drama
wow and i have a feeling that the gals
know
of course they know they must have
stunked a high health there
like no matter what you did there's they
for sure know but you did the right
thing you click i think you listen you
have a condition you did the best thing
you could do in the situation you
cleaned up you took it with you you say
god bless i'm never coming back i think
you handed yourself with as much grace
and dignity as possible in that
situation
oh yeah and i've never gone back to a
tanning bed or tanning salon ever since
because like i'm just mortified of that
ever happening again
i wonder if you took like a real watery
[ __ ] if the tanning bed could short
circuit if it could be like a danger
[Music]
get electrocuted in a puddle of [ __ ]
yeah i'll have a way to die
yeah it's pretty embarrassing i'm glad
that i finally was able to confess to
someone though you know what you're
brave you're brave you're dealing with
the condition you're doing what you can
there's nothing to be i mean it is
embarrassing and like a good camper you
left no trace yeah yeah you took it
so i'm with you so and i thank you for
sharing that story with us
and uh what was your name again
anonymous i'm not very
testing you
all right thank you you take care thanks
for sharing okay i appreciate that
you're str you're a trooper powerful
woman that's a ladyboss right there
powerful
some people just got that they got stuff
to deal with you know i have tourette's
she shits everywhere she shoots her
pants everywhere
it's a hell of a thing
and you know
women are so
in general shy about pooping you know
because it's it's gross right
so it's refreshing to hear uh
in a way
a lady owning her pooping
i'm sure she was relieved too
in more than one way
actually speaking of relief i have to
pee
you want to read some donors or
something i'll be right back
um
yeah
yeah i have to poop actually to be
totally frank
oh boy
how long is this going to be i'll be
quick it'll be cool i can tell a quick
story while you're finding some zach i
mean dan go ahead baby yeah that story
reminded me that one time that i
smuggled puke off a boat
i was with one of my friends
yeah go over the side yeah but no i was
at a sandbar with a bunch of older
people i was hanging out with one of my
friends he invited me to hang out and
there was like the sandbar where
everyone would party
and there was a guy in the boat who
started puking because he was drunk
and i'm like oh look at this guy rookie
you know trying to act cool because i
was with older people even though i
really was a rookie and then immediately
after making fun of them i had to puke
and so i didn't want i was with all
these other people and i was like oh i'm
kind of tired i'm just put this towel
over my head and then i hurled into
my hoodie
and then i wrapped it in a bag
and i just
so
here i have a hoodie on right now so
my like this no no my hoodie wasn't on i
was just using the hood as like a like a
bowl oh so you took the hood around and
yeah no i wasn't wearing it though i
just kind of like opened it up and like
put my face in it oh you weren't wearing
the hoodie yeah that makes the mechanics
a lot yeah yeah and then i wrapped it up
and i put it behind me
and i continued to talk [ __ ] about the
guy that was puking over the boat like
look at that little [ __ ] while just
like holding a bundle well smuggling
puke behind me yeah nice yeah and i made
it off the boat and nobody knew
good times
well done yeah bring a hoodie with you
guys
always
and use this stand-up tanning bed by the
way that as well
all right well let me look at some of
these donors adam troy don't
yeah because of the delay sorry
there's a delay dan
for life don't kick the guy
i would never i'm not a monster like
some people exactly yeah did i keep the
hoodie no i did not even did that
everyone saw that i didn't keep it love
i don't know about that
it was a bubba gump hoodie i wasn't too
fond of it anyways i think my mom bought
it from a bubba gump hoodie
from the the restaurant yeah i think it
was meant to be puked in
you got it there
listen this guy don't eat 50 bucks i'm
trying to read his donation okay how
dare you do it can everybody yes can
everybody chill
adam troy 50 bucks can i get a birthday
shout out from my girlfriend her name is
lauren well listen adam i don't think
you were expecting a birthday shout out
from me you probably want it from ethan
he's the star of the show he's who
you're a fan of but um
he's not here so
adam
hope your girlfriend lauren has a great
birthday
yep
[Music]
uh let's see
what else we got
that was the only one that we saved huh
let's see yeah
um
ten dollars uh if she poops herself a
lot why would she wear the thong clout
goblin
we hung up on joe to hear poop stories
justice for joe amanda with peace and
love
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not gonna say it
what else we got um
20 bucks i made a little psychedelic
rock instrumental with you and
she who shall not be named as voice
samples
in april before a frenemies died a
horrible death if you guys want to hear
it very short but it's a ride yeah i
mean post it on the subreddit or
something um
or if you're in the if you're a member
uh you're in the discord uh shared in
the there's a channel for h3tv
suggestions the suggestions have been
getting
significantly better i gotta say
we pulled quite a few videos from that
channel for the episode today so thank
you to everybody who's contributing
there yeah that wally about the good
work too you're basically doing my job
for me so appreciate you guys appreciate
you
lena's grabbing the stuff by the way to
make the shape so hopefully
[Applause]
jessica villalobo says i have a video of
abe farting on after dark episode number
52 check your dms
who's dms though
you don't specify no you don't specify
idiot i'm kidding easy i'm kidding i'm
kidding easy jessica's trying to do us a
service i'm sorry i'm kidding what the
[ __ ] damn when does your chair come in
it's gonna be a little bit
it's gonna be a little bit unfortunately
it's going to be shipped
from china so um
it'll take a little while i think they
said six to eight weeks for shipping and
if it's shipping from china probably
then take another couple weeks so
probably by the end we're hoping by the
end of the year maybe it'll be like a
you know final up of the year reveal
kind of thing in my timeout
i'm sorry i'm gonna get pissed off about
that
uh
who wants an ab official secret
library hot sauce
well he didn't handle that sauce very
well
so i don't know if that's the best
endorsement necessarily
yes this company has reselled me out to
me a few times
oh is this the one that dm'd they they
bought a cameo it ain't happening guys
it ain't happening i wouldn't feel right
guys i appreciate it but i want to feel
right thank you though
bed patrol
okay one of my favorite discord members
just uh made a five dollar donation this
is an official message from the bed
patrol a tanning bed is not a real bed
please do not use the tanning bed as a
bed with peace and love thank you bad
patrol you know
god bless you
you're doing a real service on that
discord keeping people's sleep schedules
on track
um
anybody who doesn't participate in
discord
bed patrol is a frequent uh person who
pops in to just let people know that
they should get some sleep and we
appreciate what they do for the
community i appreciate it a lot
uh sophie donates 10 bucks and says i
have m
metophobia and metaphobia
sorry if i'm mispronouncing a fear of
puke like olivia and silent library was
my nightmare i still watched it though
because i love you guys well thank you
sophie and i'm sorry
it was a month too i assure you
i shared a nightmare
uh dan i have a story about my exes
whose uncle was the hillside strangler
in l.a sorry
i don't know if i'm familiar with that
with that particular strangler
uh she was a dealer and tried to get me
to smuggle stuff for her in a sex toy i
said no don't worry
this donation
that was a ride i mean that was just one
sentence and there were a lot of twists
and turns there
the hillside
strangler oh it did auto complete
there he is
handsome
handsome guy
they always are
what's up with that i don't know it
makes it easier
[Music]
weird serial killer terrorized los
angeles between 1977 and 78 i would not
be born for another decade
so not to
oh message from ethan i'm having a mega
[ __ ]
not sure what's going on
i mean
i feel like i gotta barely
self-explanatory
nice nice you know at least i'm not in a
tanning bed look look at this guy he's
entertaining from the [ __ ] toilet
while he's shining his brains out he is
he's just natural he's a pro
we love ethan don't we folks give it up
for ethan for ethan he doesn't get
enough food
we should just talk about how great
ethan is while he's in the bathroom
let's do it he's just too kind of a soul
to hear it in front of him he's too
humble somebody just donated 13 or i'm
sorry 14 canadian dollars for poop story
triggered ethan's poop he couldn't hold
it back if only he had a purse to put it
in a true true
very true i pooped my pants
i pooped my pants
um i am a hairdresser in southwest
florida and have a client who is a one
percenter q and on lady oh hell yeah i
thought it was three percenter though
they've yeah they've lost membership
isn't one percenters the bikers
maybe there's multiple percent that call
them multiple percent i'm afraid of the
five percenters those are the ones i
don't want five percent means everything
this guy
this [ __ ] guy anyways one percenter q
and lady this woman's sister-in-law was
the woman interviewed by the plandemic
doc
uh okay
i'm not sure i know what you're talking
about mt maxie um
but i will look into it i'm googling it
right now
uh
pandemic doc
oh documentary
oh documentary i was thinking like a doc
like
your doc dr wally dan should get a nose
piercing hell no what the [ __ ] is that
suggestion madeline
[Music]
don't pierce shame dan
it's no i'm not piercing i'm just like
why would i that would be so weird did
you ever pick your ears
no i i don't have any piercings anyone
in here ever have piercings is that guys
i think zach does that kind of i don't
want embarrassing
what you got his dick pierced do you
have a piercing zack yeah i got a prince
albert nice
that's what i thought i don't understand
what he says i just go along with it
you don't know what i'm printing you
know what a prince albert is no
you really not no what's prince albert
just google it
here let me show you
oh no ethan's been gone for 10 minutes
and zack's whipping it out here we go
uh
google it oh you really want to google
it yeah prince albert okay
reaction joe exotic had one don't don't
show anything where you could see the
search results
[Music]
um
was the
something of queen victoria from the
marriage and okay prince albert piercing
okay
prince albert pierson
you're gonna look at this oh
yeah
uh wait i'm seeing a lot of different oh
it hurt i also got a jacob's ladder
uh jacob's ladder yeah chica black
oh no
google that one nick oh no
[Music]
um shelby says we need an all poop story
calling for h3tv
how is that any different than what
we've been doing today
is there a purpose for this does it not
increase no no not at all not for the
other end like the other the receiver i
feel like it might hurt
i don't feel like it would interfere
more might get tangled up in something
uh
dan tell alejandra cordero to answer my
messages please i know she's watching
sad face
tell her i'm sorry
listen tony
dude he didn't mean to do it he's
you know he just he wants you back so
bad alejandra tony um
whatever he did you know it's probably
not that bad
i mean i don't know anything about the
situation but you should
you should consider just texting them
back don't
don't disagree no i disagree sounded
like a burden
[ __ ] pony not playing with only
pepperoni dan's gonna run away so i
figured i should go to the other name's
tony pepperoni
uh 20 bucks i just want to say i love
you guys oh thanks nars we love you you
each have a special coolness that blends
together and makes an awesome show we
got a special coolness man [ __ ] yeah
like the power rangers
what power ranger would you be
uh
well blue's my favorite color but
obviously i'd be tommy
the green ranger
you think you'd be dummy
you think you'd be dumb that was a joke
but uh
are we basing them just off like what
color we like or like based off no which
which power ranger would you be
i don't know you know who would you who
would i be who billy no you wouldn't be
billy okay which one i'd be
i feel like ian would be billy maybe
yeah i could see i could see we've got
billy energy yeah i'd be ivan ooze
because that could be alfalfa
i don't miss a beat on that and i agree
wait
ivan oohs is okay for anybody in the
audience that doesn't know what we're
talking about the there was a power
rangers movie in the 90s with like maybe
not the original original cast but like
the first set of them and like this
[ __ ] villain man this is like
this is one of the cheeses
oh dude
look at that [ __ ]
costume though it's kind of sick it's
hybrid with all the slime and [ __ ] i
even [ __ ] ooze man he's a slime
salesman
so i mean he's a slime salesman wait uh
before we move on dan who would you be
i'd be tommy obviously oh you'd be
talking more as like as a jason
you know
uh
yeah maybe jason i don't know
see like a lot of kids i thought jason
was the coolest and then tommy comes
along and he likes so he [ __ ] cucks
jason so hard he's just like this is my
team now
i'm the cool one now you're just like
second [ __ ] fiddle
it somebody asking is ethan
ethan just messaged me the [ __ ] just
keeps coming out man it just keeps
coming
i should have really inspired those
roger that
i'm giving live poop updates
to the audience it's nice right now you
guys at home
i'm sure some of you are using the
bathroom as well enjoy it
yeah ivan news was the best villain and
my favorite power rangers movie also i
love you all thank you yeah no he kind
of kind of ruled slime salesman
also i'm sure ethan's watching hi ethan
oh you think he's watching
for sure
i don't think he has any interest in
watching this
dan
love a b check your instagram dms oh
this is the person that said they uh
sent um
[Music]
what the [ __ ] did they say they said
i don't remember yeah i have no clue i
forgot what am i looking for it's from
uh look for jessica villalobos
dm from jessica vilobus
real good
there was gossip of billy from the og
power rangers getting bullied a lot back
in during the show a b would fit
perfectly for billy okay then i'm billy
no
what i don't know if i buy that billy
what the actor got bullied i buy that
he's a [ __ ] nerd no i'm kidding i
love billy hold on let me look at he
stuck around for the longest out of any
of them like out of the original crew
probably got them all fired
he was the uh
was that the the kid that was the blue
ranger who was that yeah that's billy
that's billy
that's billy he ain't got [ __ ] on ivory
news man i'll tell you that much
look up elizabeth april on youtube and
you all react to her my q anon brother
has evolved to her evolved to her
and i'm a little sad about it lol
yeah i don't know i'm not familiar with
that one i have a feeling i know the
type there's quite a few of them out
there
on youtube and
yeah it's uh pretty [ __ ] up
let's see elizabeth april international
psychic teacher and truth seeker uh you
know there's nothing i love more than
seeking the truth i just need to say
something real quick i realized billy
was bullied he said he's bullied for his
sexuality so uh
for his sexuality yeah he was bullied
for being gay it says i am back but
yeah so i feel bad you guys are pretty
deep what the [ __ ] is this ivan ooze
yeah do you remember
we were discussing what power rangers
would be and zack said he'd be ivan
who's which
is kind of
kind of awesome i'm not gonna lie thank
you look how [ __ ] cool his costume is
it does look sick it's honestly really
good
the prosthetic's insane
love him well that was a big show at the
time they probably had a pretty big
budget this was the movie
i'm back i'm sure i'm so sorry
thank you guys for carrying the show and
my absence that's the you know hey it's
live
and sometimes as we learned from our
previous caller [ __ ] happens
precisely that was a double flush i
don't know where that came from it's
like i didn't
well are you ready for some ground up
garlic radishes and lemon juice oh we
got it already well i think it's in the
works lena's got it oh yeah for sure i'm
ready apparently
if i would have only
drinking that 10 minutes ago i would
have cured my
ibs or whatever
all right we've got so much to get to
how'd you guys do by the way that was
like a solid like
we're having fun we were vibing he told
a story about vomiting into his shirt
and casting it overboard at scenes i did
i did not kiss it but why did you puke
in your shirt when you're on a boat
because he was talking [ __ ] about
somebody else puking and then like two
minutes later got seasick and had to
puke and so he didn't want anybody to
know so he clandestinely
into a sweater and hit it
i was with a bunch of older that's
pretty high level shame right there like
i would probably rather just be
embarrassed
but also you're gonna have puke all over
your shirt how do you hide that i know
we we were i was in a bathing suit you
said hoodie on your body i puked no i
puked in a hoodie
did you throw the hoodie over them no i
wrapped it in like a little target bag
and i smuggled it to shore why are you
why are you so insecure about them
thinking you puke
well i don't i mean now i wouldn't give
a [ __ ] i mean i at the time were you
i think i was like 22
[Music]
i don't know i was with older kids i
don't know
kids you're 22. older dudes
older females fully grown men older
friends
interesting
so you took the puke to shore did you
throw out the hoodie or did you salvage
it did throw it out that's good my
favorite bubba gum shrimp hoodie
here also with some discussion what do
you think ethan
should i get a nose piercing no please i
agree
somebody suggested it was like dan you
should get a nose piercing i said no way
and then cam just photoshopped that it's
not a good look no
that's a bad look
all right here we've got you know we
talk about uh we kid the uh
the uh chiropractors on the show we kid
them
you kid kid yeah we kid them i mean the
chiropractors get up to all the craziest
[ __ ] they're like and it's all just
pseudoscience there's always some new
weird thing here's a [ __ ] with a
hammer
and chisel
oh ab you just referred i know i know
i'm so i'm sorry [ __ ] i'm sorry wait
what happened i said i said the f word
i said
there was older females on the boat like
an incel oh insular but i was describing
me during my in-cell days so it makes
sense you know i mean i i shouldn't say
it i'm gonna say something i don't i i
probably shouldn't say older females
[Music]
anyway here's a cover let's uh
let's move to the chiropractor who's
basically this is a man this is not a
slab of marble this is a human being
made of flesh and bone
not for long
oh yeah
whatever he did already it seems like
he's handling it well
this is like what you do when the mob is
like
shaking you down for money you owe
but but this guy's paying him to do this
not a vampire bro
oh
[ __ ]
hell no dude
no
this is so intense
this is modern day witchcraft i mean do
you mind it looks like rasputin
guy doing it though this is not science
guys
he's literally driving a railroad into
his back
he's coughing up blood he's not doing
good man it's not working
i guess the theory probably that makes
people think it works is that you create
so much pain it makes you forget about
your back pain
[Music]
yeah this is a deep tissue i don't know
what's the problem
this dude is not happy either he's like
clearly grunting in pain
this is what i'm talking about this is
the equivalent of like bloodletting i
don't know how in this day and age this
[ __ ] is still happening yeah and it
definitely is i mean i i don't think
most chiropractors do that to be fair
well
i'll be uh listen chiropractic
people don't like when i say this but
it's such a [ __ ] field
short of like stretching doing stretches
and
and then and strengthening muscles
anything else outside that is total
uh pseudoscience this is you at the
chiropractor
this was so good i got to watch it twice
well i
if you want in the doc i found this
guy's tick tock account and there's a
million
olivia says she loves uh cairo vids and
cracking yeah a lot of people do
i love the ones where it's basically
just like a girl in the tightest spandex
possible and the guy's like sliding his
hands up her ass and cracking her butt
cheeks what was the guy's name on
youtube uh dr
mike dr jason dr jason
somehow dr jason makes dr mike seem
classy right
[ __ ] you don't use your first
name with doctor it makes you seem like
a trashy freak
dr jason
yeah i do want to see i'm very curious
about this guy's tick tock this guy is a
master at his craft
oh baby look at all this juicy content
i'm trying to find a high view this one
is six million see
this is the same poor [ __ ] he's
crying
he's laughing i think
but this is the same guy
okay well let's see
i think he's laughing
he's about to slam him with a dildo
i mean the truth is that some people
just have such bad back pain that
they're just desperate for anything so i
understand i wish there i wish we had
better solutions for backs back pain
because it seems like there's not a lot
of great stuff
short of like becoming a drug addict
which obviously is a horrible solution
this is
this is uh
this is a political prisoner this is not
a man being treated
he's in the gulag yeah look at the uh
[Music]
stop doing it to yourself bro
all right put back on the gown
get back in yourself feel good
[Laughter]
bme pain olympics
oh not the cracking
i didn't even hear
cracking dude it's not even cracking
[Music]
why that's 20 million it's like six
million views
poor man is paying for this
pain to have this done to him
this is kind of the best job for like
sadis so we just want to hurt people
let's just punch him in the back as hard
as he can
somebody in chat why are we watching
straight up isis torture videos right
now it is he probably sells coffins in
the waiting lobby
[Music]
i mean i it
sounds like porn oh it's the nutcracker
kind of is porn
um we'll get to that here's another one
you guys want to keep i mean i'm i'm i'm
personally fascinated i think and by the
way it's the same guy in every video
um oh wait here's a new guy no yeah
there are different guys wait i want to
see the new guy it's get cracked
don't you want to see the new guy
the skinny dude they're right what'd you
say
yeah
this guy's gonna break in half
[Laughter]
all right buddy
we're gonna see how strong your back is
oh no he's got the fork the tuning fork
this guy's whole treatment method is
just slamming
oh oh he handled he took it like a champ
he's wondering he's just dead
he looks like e.t when he's
doing this to a corpse yo
how can there be
oh oh we got some movement it could have
just been a great spouse it started as
hard again
muscle spasms started his heart up
oh i heard him go oh
you know how can you have a whole
chiropractic practice just around
slamming people with a mallet
honestly i'd rather take opiates at this
point i'd rather just [ __ ] become a
drug addict yeah then get slammed with
the mallet oh my lord
um well i don't know i love this [ __ ]
chiropractor it's castlevania
that's awesome
[Laughter]
they got they got a 10 i mean the
vampires they gotta tenderize their meat
before they eat it right
that's awesome
oh god good one kim
i'm gonna look for one more victim that
looks interesting oh here's see here's a
scientific video
i'd like to see what happens when you
smash it with the mallet
part of me
what am i getting from a little afraid
of these like anatomy videos i don't
wanna
huh
oh hey we got the stuff we got the stuff
well
let's show the ingredients come here
so we got a blender too
do we have a machine yeah we do
holy [ __ ] okay so we have a ton of
brownies
okay let's show we can put the
ingredients in the machine and then
blend it okay we have fresh garlic
thank you so disgusting you gonna hit
this lina yeah you want some
where you going lena you gonna take a
hit of this
no she said no no thank you missing out
so how much should i put in here so this
is the wally p cure for everything yeah
we gotta bottle this
like you should sell this to the super
troopers 100 bucks per bottle here's
everything
so what's the recipe i mean here's a
beet
a radish right
radishes
for
dude was already kind of
in there so i'm not really sure what the
proportions are i think you should just
screenshot you should just dump all the
garlic because it looked like it was
primarily garlic in there pull up the
screenshot yeah because i want to get i
want to get this right apparently i'm
going to lose weight
yeah weight loss by the way you guys
hungry
yes sir
mexican
you are hungry
yeah sure this is
oh yeah
those are little we got big ass radishes
wait he doesn't he doesn't know what i'm
saying it's like it's already kind of in
there right now well there you go yeah
okay so wait oh the cowley that's a lot
of lemon juice yeah it's a dc so this
is the base there's three radishes
yeah but those are much smaller radishes
i would put in two well i guess we're
making for a bunch of people let's do
three radishes all the garlic yeah show
this
this is
like uh this is like at least 30
uh cloves
yeah
okay
quite a bit of lemon juice actually
[Music]
lemon juice pure
royal
lemon juice
wait how is this only 25 percent juice
[Music]
what else is in there i would just think
it would be a hundred
percent you know
but okay
whatever so wally use we gotta use it
right whatever it is
so it's gonna be a lot based on
yeah this is gonna be foul as hell more
i think more how much just
more definitely more yeah he says he
hits a whole glass of it
yeah
i think i think i'll just divvy this up
i think a sip will suffice for us so
we've got half a bottle of lemon juice
got like 30 cloves
three radishes
that's good we're not slamming the whole
thing
well we'll share it with the shares
we have one machine you want this all
yourself kinda
i think we all know what blending looks
like
thank you
exciting particularly looking forward to
this but i mean it's all good i like
lemon juice like garlic like radish
don't love but it's okay sometimes
decent decent
i mean i love garlic too but not i don't
usually drink it to the dome
i just don't usually drink it very soon
you go to hell
hey wally we're trying to give it a
chance wait are you saying it's going to
kill me wally you said it would save me
here let's find one more victim oh he's
going in for the wait this is a child
because if it is i'm out
yeah it is
okay let's not watch the child
child endangerment straight up
nobody should let this man hear a child
all right
stop it wally
all right here's the mallet boy
these poor guys must be suffering a lot
to endure this psychological
psychotherapy
and not like psychotherapy right
psychotic therapy yeah thank you
one more for the good guys come on now
home run
all right blend it up real good baby
don't be shy back there
somebody said it looks like a nice
little strawberry smoothie
yeah
okay
i'm glad we got that footage yeah
first time i've ever seen something
blended actually
from that angle
certainly from that angle yeah
uh what else we got
wait i heard gagging that bad
you alright oh you're right back there
did you
that guy pukes from [ __ ] anything
gagged from garlic smell
i mean that much garlic is
i don't know we should we shouldn't you
might be gagging in a second i mean
you oh here's a video kodak mom and
kodak mom
kodak blacks this rapper
i'm not familiar with this music but he
seems like pretty off the rails and
anyway here he is are we sure this is
his mom because i saw this story
this was all over the place so this is
for sure his mom i mean i don't know
what his mom looks like so
that's what everybody's saying i mean it
was all over the internet yesterday hold
on let's do a cross reference
somebody cross referenced that one oh
that's mom black because if it is this
[ __ ] is so wild
his mom
there's a picture of her it looks like
that woman hold up you see
maybe he's passing out the smoothies it
look really nice pink hue to it
yeah that's his mom for sure
okay this is crazy thank you baby
wow
that looks good like if i didn't know
any better i'd be like yo this what is
this
so this
to your health eh
and that's it's not as bad as i
it's not as bad as i was fearing it was
gonna smell
it just smells like glass garlic
you know it smells like his toilet water
kind of
it's not right
it's making it real dirty it was like a
like a salad dressing or something did
you wash these radishes maybe yeah yeah
okay no you didn't
wally doesn't watch this we gotta it's
awesome so much lemon juice and garlic
in there all right am i good to just
take a sip like i don't have to slam
this do i you have to drink it all if
you want to live forever i i'm
perfectly okay with dying cheers to
wally
to wally p okay
let's wake up
whoa
it's like
i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna say it's
good but it's it's not anywhere as bad
as i thought it would no it's not bad
don't say it like it's good it's
definitely not good i'm enjoying it
uh-huh
wait are you slamming that whole thing
put on zach i've been
i'm enjoying it
zach's taking it
bro and then how do
[Music]
for 30 minutes to actually be like oh i
feel sick bro i gotta puke
oh yeah
[Music]
that's pretty foul
i'll be honest my tummy
doesn't like that
i guess we'll find yeah i'm
i'm chilling on the on the sip that i
took i'm not going to slam that
i mean my mouth is very garlicky it
tastes it tastes like so you're right it
tastes like soda beer something but yeah
well it's like a soup i mean if you add
some veggies some oil some salt right
guatemala schwarteman
watermelon
what is shawarma
shawarma with garlic
here's wally he's actually opening a
juice store
so you can get that there
he's a juicer now i'll be his first
customer
i could take another swig of this
honestly but
you want to live forever
my stomach kind of rumbled after that
step
what's that how you feeling
fine
he's not fine there's no way you're fine
after slamming that
do your farts later are gonna be so
garbage
i mean i could probably clean a bathtub
with this yeah
totally
i just why is it frothy was it foamy
what what made it foamy just the blender
whips a lot of air into it that happens
i'm gonna take one more sip
i'll join you
you gotta get past the foam which is
kinda hard
it's lingering in my mouth i don't want
to like that
[Music]
it kind of like
cuts your tongue
if it what it cuts your tongue
why is eb the only one with a
non-transparent glass
oh how much did you drink amy
you heard me how much did i drink
a sip
okay whatever
it's fine
no he's like [ __ ]
don't do this dan wait is it empty yes
don't do this dan wait love how did you
know love you love you dude thank you
wait you didn't even pour yourself any
what what why are you so afraid of this
clearly you didn't learn your lesson
last week you did that everyone's
snitching on me now
wait hold on hold on i'm still not happy
with what you did last week so how did
you av why would you you wouldn't even
pour it in there huh
i i can't do that [ __ ]
i'm not doing i can't aren't those like
lebanese flavors yeah i like garlic man
i hate garlic
can't do it
come on now
wow that's enough i didn't want to kill
the segment so i just played along if
you put a little bit in your cup we
wouldn't have known
yeah
the empty cup wow dead giveaway
didn't expect to be
backstabbed from behind shame
yeah i would never do such a thing if
you should kick me the week prior mm-hmm
all right it's okay
zach zack drank
it's really not bad
but i didn't see that i was expecting it
to be
absolutely vile and make me gag
it's not
that bad
let's see if there's any calls this he
had his testicles shattered sorry
he had in a large testicle condition and
wants to tell his story
his testicle was shattered like a like a
[ __ ] ball of glass i just hit my
balls
and heist tell me which one sounds most
interesting in high school a kid took a
photo of him [ __ ] in the bathroom
chaos and sued fed enough [ __ ] no no
[ __ ] yeah
this guy has a scientology story was
trapped in the church for eight hours
story about crazy christians uh
wants ethan's perspective having a bad
week
need relationship advice and those
usually go pretty badly yeah
so
i guess that's a no for me on all of
them
um oh kodak black now this is
interesting right here boy
okay
you ever dance with your mom like this
[Music]
yep yep
so he's getting he's dancing with his
mom trying to kiss her on the lips
he's grabbing her ass that's where it
goes off the rails
because like kiss you want to give your
mom a peck is can be sweet i guess but
the ass grabbing right there that's when
something ain't right with that
apparently he got out of jail somebody
said lock him up again
i mean what do you guys think is this
just innocent goofing or is this uh
some oedipus [ __ ] i feel like that's
[ __ ] up dude
i mean i can't imagine grabbing my mom's
ass that is not something i'd ever want
to be interested in yeah
i think kodak is a clone
you think he's a clone this isn't the
real one yeah so it's not his real mom
that's a big theory after he came out of
yay he was completely changed i
what
yep there's some weird videos kodak
black clone
not to be a buzz kill but i'm i'm
reading that he's been struggling with
some problems lately
he had some weird posts on sunday about
being lonely and sad and
i just want to point that out you ever
been lonely and sad and wanted to [ __ ]
your mom
[Laughter]
i mean we're all [ __ ] got issues bro
it was a little bit more uh
well read it what the [ __ ] are you
trying to defend myself i'm saying
suicidal posts oh okay yeah that is sad
was it because this video came out and
everybody's clowning on him this
unfortunately came out
right after
[Music]
that redefines mommy makeup day
i do see some stuff uh about
his clone rumors though so well i mean i
hope i hope the original kodak is doing
all right at 11 am
8 am pacific time if that's where you're
at so check out what do you okay well
there you have it kodak wants to [ __ ]
his mom i mean i don't see another way
to interpret that but we wish him well
and um just
don't have
don't reproduce i guess i don't know
you don't want to have kids with your
mom that's for sure
right you guys back me up there correct
yes
his mom
oh boy what's it called when you're in
love with your mom is like
oedipus
and edibus complex
edifice
of course
didn't know what's his mom
he does
why don't you take a seat i think that's
called the kodak black complex at this
point
uh how do you want to [ __ ] your mom like
man that's that's some weird deep deep
deep trauma right there boy i'll just be
your secret lover
like
oh that's deep trauma right there
that's down bad
it's definition
definition down bad do you mind
i only took a tiny sip of that [ __ ]
nasty ass [ __ ] and my my tummy is
grumbling at me yeah yeah yeah yeah the
second one helped me so maybe you hit it
again oh you'll be cleared
interesting how long by the way ela
we don't have help today with theodore
so ela's at home by herself with the
baby and she's been with all day so
i have obligations to what time you got
to go
uh i think well how long we've been
going up i do two hours yeah i want to
do like three four hours five hours
okay
it was like get home now
come on it's a five hour episode and we
can do another hour
well we have to get to the kim
kardashian [ __ ]
oh and i gotta do the zach farting
segment too yeah
so hold on let me just say i love world
of shirts if you guys don't know he's
uh this character that walks around new
york
i don't know and when you sent me this i
was oh you don't know who world of
shirts is no i don't i don't do tick
tock he's walk he just goes all around
new york and he goes
i own this town
right that's his thing he's been in all
kinds of he's on the spectrum
and he like he's just been in all these
uh
like people come up to him and they want
to take a photo and then he's trying to
charge people for a photo or people will
be like
interrupting his tick tocks
and he goes don't interrupt this is a
whole saga and then there was one where
he stomped on a fish that was
pretty foul i mean that one was [ __ ]
up well not funny
i don't know
then he was recently in cancun
getting blackout drunk and everyone was
worried about him because he was like
off the radar
it's a whole thing here this i think
this is when he disappeared
can you drink the water in mexico
[Laughter]
come on now
that's [ __ ] funny boy
what where's the laughter just me
yeah
he's a super stop it dan he's a super
interesting uh account anyway he
recently the reason i'm talking about
him he recently did an ad
for his soap company
and the person that paid him to do it
was uh
not happy with his first read so here is
his second read the owner of the soap
company said that she didn't make enough
sales from the last video
she was yelling on the phone with me for
15 minutes
she wanted me to emphasize how much i
love the moldy tea soap
this is her soap
that's irish spring also there's free
shipping
check the link in my bio or at std soaps
in the description this is totally me
when i have to do a makeup
that's so [ __ ] amazing come on i was
thinking about yeah you probably relate
to having a razor was there an original
ad or is he just joking no no no there
was uh let me find it for sure there was
because i tried to and i wasn't able
maybe he erased it
maybe
oh you couldn't find the original ad
this is the best yeah because again when
you send me this i was baffled by like
what was supposed to be interesting or
funny about it
you're baffled
i really was i
this is the fun i guess i don't have the
background i don't have the backstory of
this guy i don't know this is funny love
if you know him on tick-tock i think
you'd find it more funny yeah i'm sure
i'm sure
without that context though i was just
confused genuinely and then i tried to
find the original ad and couldn't find
it anywhere wake up dan
also because you don't like when ethan
messes up ads too so maybe a hit
the next time someone
makes us do a make good i'm gonna read
this verbatim
she was yelling on the phone with me for
15 minutes
she wanted me to emphasize how much i
love the moldy cheese soap
this is her so bro that's irish spring
that's not does that look like artisan
soap to you
that's literally irish spring right so
again this is supposed to be a joke
right no this is real as it gets bro
this is world if you're saying this is
reality tv oh okay
i'm seeing some people in the chat
saying that it is a bit he's just doing
i mean i'm looking more into i mean it
seems like it's a bit
i don't know bro why would he be holding
up irish springs ltd soaps that wait
that doesn't sound like a real company
yeah what's std soaps
natural not israeli influence soap at an
affordable price okay didn't ask about
that
oh i'm about to go to this website
hold on
so here's their website
breaking bad blue sky meth soap
horny jalapeno lip balm
i'm afraid that um
i
i don't know though is this a real sight
moldy cheese soap
this is what he said he was holding
maybe he mistakenly didn't have the soap
and just showed
like can you buy [ __ ] on this like this
actually seems like a real sight they
have a cart yeah
and it makes sense that like a meme soap
company
would
sponsor
world of shirts
then get really mad about it
and yell at him for 15 minutes
i think okay that case i think it's
staged it's staged but they're for him
to do that exactly yeah
that they're yeah
i don't know what's with the casual
anti-semitism though the owner of the
silver maybe anti-israel
not israeli influence soap
come on now
no not a jewish-owned company
their second post on that account also
looked like it was something about
somebody having aids or something
yeah there's aids fungal deodorant
okay it seems like it's some real epic
uh cringy epic
[ __ ] lay epic uh
i'm not down with world of shirts i
gotta tell you i'm gonna be frank you
don't know anything about him but
everything i'm finding out is just not
well he doesn't vet his sponsors he's
world of shirts he got paid and he's
given my shout out i don't i think
you're you're you're eating the onion a
little bit right now
you know him he's on the spectrum dan
okay
so what am i what onion am i eating
except this [ __ ] he's drinking the
garlic yeah not eating drinking the
garlic
no this guy's serious all right who's
watches world of shirts back me up i've
seen him yeah i mean i don't watch him
all the time but you can't you can't
avoid him he's all over
he's the real deal
but again in dan's defense he's not on
tick-tock so
not familiar yeah but he then exactly
he's out of his element you can't sit
here okay
okay you it's really funny it's a really
funny joke it's a great it's a great one
the owner of the soap company said that
she's
making up sales from the last video
she was yelling on the phone with me for
15 minutes
dude dan is such a [ __ ] hater man
goddamn
i'm coming out against world of shirts
okay
any other plot proclamations martin
luther
he can take the heat
thank
you um
let's do the fart thing because we
actually
are the kim k thing let's do the kim k
thing and then we'll do zack has
continually claimed that he can tell the
diff when we listen to wendy williams he
swears that he could tell the difference
between a fart
and not a fart based on the wave
length of the sound that's right
there's no [ __ ] way that could be
true i guess uh put it to the challenge
well
i'm pretty excited to
to find out yeah
but uh so yeah you know as you guys know
kim kardashian was threatening me in the
dms
based on like wiki feed i had said that
i was coming for her
because she was like showing off her
feet and she sent me dms basically
threatening me well what's crazy is we
went to new york
and i was in the hotel me and either
we're leaving our hotel in the lobby and
i see
there's like all these there's like
eight black suvs and who do i see
coming through the lobby
uh is her mom
uh
chris
chris
the legend
she goes she's so serious takes herself
i'm not kidding she literally they're
staying at our hotel what a coincidence
right you don't believe me i'll show you
the video i took
they come walking through the lobby and
this chris she's cruising through there
like she's in the matrix bro like i'm
sorry
it's like the old saying goes the devil
works hard but kris jenner works harder
[Music]
what the [ __ ] she do
she work hard she she works hard okay
she built enough
so anyway i saw them there
there was like a whole group you guys
think i'm kidding but it was such a
weird coincidence the whole family was
staying
in the same hotel as us
um and there was like a whole group of
people and paparazzi and eight suvs like
the goddamn president and here's the
video i took from our room
there you go guys
he's got his hand on the handle
i told you i told you it's hurt oh yeah
love goes
i'm reading the whatsapp chat love goes
are you sure if you're not in new york
then it's not her because she's in new
york
can i handle it
you said are you in new york cause she's
in new york right now yeah i was like
yes i am in new york love yeah that
supported your theory you thank you
exactly oh guys
he's got his hand on the handle
i told you i told you it's her love what
do you mean are we in new york
yes we're in new york it's kim i'm i saw
her mom dude
get ready he's got his hand on the
handle she was doing snl i guess
don't [ __ ] blink
don't blink right now [ __ ] she was
the big moment chasing
all been waiting for
she came here because
[ __ ]
she came here
clearly like uh were those olympic uh
ice skaters nancy kerrigan she came here
and this is evidence that i'm gonna have
to send to my attorneys and to the
police come on now
could be playing td
balloons td6
right now
yo
what okay so kim has a fleet of six suvs
like she's the president or some [ __ ]
like the u.n envoy
i mean damn girl what the [ __ ] you just
made a sex tape
skins
how did she become a billionaire you
lisa skims
from skins from selling spandex
is that true
[Music]
skins you can make a billion dollars
naming a
product skims that's interesting
but yeah there's like one two three four
five six literally six
black suvs like damn dude
seven black suvs
here here we go i hear noise who is that
that's chris nobody cares kylie nobody
cares
bodyguards nobody cares chris and kylie
this is for chris and kylie
what nobody cares
wait not kylie it was the one nobody
cares about what's her name
chloe it was chris and chloe
nobody cares that's it oh there's more
there's more
there's more what's happening maybe it's
their fat brother is it the fat brother
no it's not the fat brother okay the
president's out of here the president is
gone they're pulling away
the crowd is dispersing
and uh boy
we all gathered for
what's her name again khaleesi
what's her name chloe they gathered for
chloe and chris
hey come on
um well if i was going to send someone
to break up my feed i would have sent
chloe to do it because she couldn't
serve tommy i think you're just too
close
you know what i mean yeah it's all
something weird um
the fun's over
yeah why do you record vertical
um i could it was it was the angle was
so tight it was the only way i could get
a good shot okay all right yeah
a great shot
well it was it was hard man i was trying
to see the action but what a weird
coincidence so that was that was the
confrontation
when did no this was the confrontation i
caught her outside and i was like you
[ __ ] been talking [ __ ] about my feet
can you make me skinnier too
thanks
wow you got right up in her face does it
look like we're looking at each other
still yeah no it does yeah yeah
absolutely what do you guys think the
clickbait what is that what is the chat
thing
did you click this does it look real
real enough
that open chat and see
god this cup stinks man it's filling up
my space
my
my mouth is still just dust yeah
yeah i want to read the chat um thank
you maybe
uh
so do we like the thumbnail let's try it
let's throw it up
and um
10 bad clickbait people are saying
it's bad boomer energy pull let's do a
poll yeah i like the polls okay
the thing is worst clickbait title yet
um see that's not good it needs to be
something like
i don't think anyone cares about kim k
unless they think that like we actually
interacted with her so here's what i'm
thinking is kim k
spit my face
in new york it's gotta be something like
that
you have to go further than you've ever
thought you could go before you know
you want to change it to that
uh amy's saying we need to clarify that
she didn't message me well i'm not ready
to clarify that i haven't looked through
my
unread messages yet
it's possible am i putting up a poll
yeah what what is the do they like
the thumbnail title is it clickbait
enough or do we need to stretch title
further click bait enough
do the click baits even work someone
asks [ __ ] yeah they do it's insane
so the the answers is yes it's good
click bait or no keep working on it wait
yes it's good yes
no it you can do better no yeah you can
do better yeah the clickbait works
insanely good like
when we post an episode we can see how
it's comparing to the other videos and
if it's on the bottom of the list
if we go in and workshop it
um
you can see an immediate bump in views
it's pretty it's pretty cool all right
pulls up because you have the access to
the real-time views so you change that
[ __ ]
and then as soon as you upload the title
and thumbnail you see those views spike
up 25 you're like god damn
people are saying no good evenly
distributed but yeah it is slight lean
towards know you can do better
what else do we talk about this episode
[Music]
do they know that we mean like a better
click bait not
do better in general oh well it says yes
it's good click bait it specifically
says that and no you can do better
oh here's one this is a more accurate
one actually
i'll pull this up this is more accurate
to what happened
massive hands
oh look at your jaw too
did you make me skinnier i still look
funny dude you look like the [ __ ]
chatter like the chad meme
chad and virgin whoever this guy is
so what have we talked about we talked
about a lot of stuff let's see maybe the
kim k thing is
if we take a new approach like james
charles
uh just peed in my basement
a little combo action
um
uh
james charles is good what can we say
about his merch
wally p no
yeah james charles is a good one
kodak black goes on a mission uh
to
[ __ ] his own mom
what about um
zach analyzes farts what makes that guy
the food god like i just don't get it
he's the food god that's what he is on
instagram tic toc
his name is jonathan chabon why is he a
food god
he really he like rebranded himself he
was a pr dude i'm sure he was maybe he
makes good food
no he just eats it i'm fat i'm a food
god he ain't [ __ ] oh he's like a food
reviewer
no
not really
by the way if you guys want to see
love sent this don't worry exactly don't
worry about it like this is what happens
when you get a good title thumbnail like
this is the post and then when you get
that good one you see that immediate
bump and you're like okay let's go
and it makes a huge difference like
seriously
it's fun too i kind of like the whole
workshopping aspect let's try james
charles
james charles
um
hi sisters
whoa the whole ensemble in harmony what
can we do about this uh james charles
busted again
on a kid's face
and parentheses
[Music]
a little twist
[Music]
and you got buzzed by ian for that one
that was brutal i'm sorry ian as a side
note the food god legally changed his
name to food god what a [ __ ] creep
what is wrong with these people these
people are so [ __ ] in the head like
bro you're so uninteresting you change
your name to food god bro what do people
call you food
you know i assume they call them food
god
either if they're trying to be
respectful well hold on is his first
name was it changed to food god
god food god one word okay so food god
yeah
he changed his name to an instagram
handle
god bless what a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that
guy
literally hate him for that
all right james charles uh
do people care do they click for james i
think more than kim
i don't know about that
but who cares about kim
apparently a lot of people she's very
famous and just hosted saying but like
the thing is
[Music]
hmm
who cares about james
he got like 800 likes on his merch post
people are saying no
okay
so let me let me ask this let's do
another poll do they think that we
should stick with kim and perfect
the title thumbnail
or move to james
roger
being
busting once again
stop stop saying that i don't like it
uh stick
with kim or
pivot
to james
kim all the way
baby
desperation
[Music]
here we go
see what the audience says
where's the poll come on zach so what
does the food do you know what the food
god does i'm still kind of he's i don't
think he does food he just eats food i
think he's literally just oh wow that's
food like he'll go to a pizza place bill
try pizza he's trying to be like dave
pork boy
i guess
no but he reviews the pizza right this
guy's just like just eats it yeah he
keeps saying that he's not a food
reviewer he just shows off food he's
just like oh i'm eating [ __ ] food
that makes you a god welcome we all eat
food it's a [ __ ] function of being a
human of being a living creature anyway
people are saying kim with a blowout
yeah
so they don't like the title thumb show
show the thumb again let's see
so we're gonna have to go further with
this let's i think let's use this one
interesting
that is pretty good this is good
what about this one
[Music]
james charles giving him a little
little uh ear willie there
i heard he's into that
a little combo smaller hands though for
sure maybe put james charles face on i
don't hate that thumbnail i'm not gonna
lie it's so [ __ ] come on it's really
funny
funny doesn't get clicks
how do i crop my wait what is this what
did you just send love
somebody donate fifty dollars suggested
changing the title to ethan dies of
dysentery well that's pretty accurate
yeah how do i crop my hoodie how can i
contact james
[Music]
wait i want to see the answer to that
yeah
you know what was that faq the last part
i'm gonna go to the page because i wanna
where is my hoodie
where is my [ __ ] hoodie
the bottom sometimes in the picture
wait wait wait
where am i i'm lost there's too many
this is oh how do i contact let's get
glam
sister support how do i get featured on
sister apparel social media
right above that
how can i contact james hey sisters we
know how much you love james but we do
not have any contact details for our
amazing boss
sincerely james
we'll find you
he'll find you yeah he'll yeah we'll
call you don't you don't call us don't
worry he'll come knocking
oh man
i love it
well
oh interesting
let's see
so let's pull up the thumbnail here
uh kim kardashian spit in my face
kim kardashian queefed on me
kim kardashian
attacked me
hiring my audience
to help me pick a thumbnail
wow
all right let's do the farting uh
let's do the farting thing okay
um
i thought we'd be able to pick one out a
little easier but these things are
delicate
zach says
here's a clip of zach just to update you
guys on the outlandish claims he's made
we're going to put him to the test
you file of it i've seen a lot of
fartwell oh here we go zach is in the
laboratory it's it looks like a fart i'm
zach you're telling me you can tell it
between a fart and a whoop yes
yes i can really no shot it's funny i
read an article and it says that every
time she says something messed up that
it's karma like she was making from
joaquin phoenix's cleft lip well anyway
uh zack's talking a huge game i i don't
think you can tell the difference
between a whoop and a fart
i guess we'll find out so the game is
the farthest we are going to put zach to
the test
actually shout out to if to one of our
someone in our audience recommended this
valerie t said zach should be given
multiple wavelength files to view some
farts some non-farts and see if he can
identify the difference or shout out to
valerie
fantastic idea we have three rounds
with three farts each for a total of
nine fart sounds
dan has both the answer key and the
sound bites to play
so round one this is easy it's going to
get more challenging as we move on zach
okay
do we have two wave files side by side
and um
you're gonna basically mark the one that
you think is a fart with an
x one is a far the other is cows moving
for example you're gonna tell us which
is the fart okay now are you gonna play
the sound for us dan and then he has
access we're gonna see the wav file as
well yeah so if you go if you look at
the section in the dot oh the quiz here
yeah so open that up and so here i can
do it i just sent the link uh in discord
as well in our chat
so you can up on your screen
i can put this on the on the screen yeah
and then you're gonna play the sound for
us
after when we reveal yes so for example
in this first one oh it's just based on
the audio right that's the whole point
okay he's got to analyze the wave how
long is this because this is a long ass
wavelength how can you fart that long oh
it's just no it's very brief it's zoomed
way in
you've got to see the detail to be able
to okay zach so this is this is easy
okay
stage one so part of what makes it easy
in stage one is we're actually going to
tell him
what
like one is a fart and the other is this
and then he has to pick so like i said
fairly easy okay so for round one
one is a fart
and one is an air horn okay
interesting all right zach
tell us which one is the fart a or b i
believe it's a
so a is the fart you're saying yes
that's interesting because the air horn
is more of a
that to me seems a consistent but a fart
is a
so i'm going to say b is the fart okay
well
zack said it was a let's listen to what
a is
[Music]
i'm sorry but that was the air horn b
here's b
yeah
gross
fair enough all right hold on now zach
uh let's not let's take an early lead
let's not gloss over the fact that
we're already off to it maybe it needs a
warm up stinky start here shake it out
zach take it out come on let me let me
let one out record
yeah all right so now we're on round two
um
do you have any intel yeah so round two
uh one is a fart and one is a splash
splash yes interesting
um splash
well the thing is there are different
types of farts
so therefore they're going to look
different and sound different therefore
we're in the easy mode still go ahead uh
i'm gonna go b
b is the fart yeah i think ethan okay so
let's let's think this through here a
splash
well it could be like a
like splashy splashy or it could be a
like a
doink yeah
but looking at the wave files i'm
thinking you know
so because a could be a
right like a spurter
but then b could be a
you don't know what kind of fart it is
the problem with a is that there's too
much silence correct
for it to be a splash
because i feel like a splash will have a
lot of residual sound
so i'm going to take a risk here i'm
taking a risk here
but i think a
is going to be the fart
okay so you you have opposite answers
again right yes yeah all right so zach
said it was b
uh let's take a listen to b
i'm sorry here's a
oh
wait that was all one
oh wow
ew
it's a white one
i think it was literally labeled wet one
dude
ethan my fart game is pretty good it's
pretty good
all right well so one more easy one you
check out number three okay what are the
options uh
so one is a fart the other is jake paul
saying stop it
wait wait
what's the sound bite stop it oh it is
about the bullying the a is definitely
the fart stop it
yeah i see that zach um stop it you can
kind of see it yeah
then obviously the wavelengths on the a
is like a good classic you scroll down a
little bit more because you're you're
yeah that's like a classic
wavelength
stop it i don't see how b isn't jake
paul i'm going to agree with zach okay
so you guys are on the same page this
time yeah so the a is the fart is what
you're saying yes all right let's take a
listen today
congratulations you both nailed it all
right zach
stop it
yeah you can clearly see that right okay
all right so ethan's three for three
zack's got one point but it's about to
get a little bit more difficult maybe
zach is he's gonna shine you know he has
that high level fart dar yeah maybe we
would make it a little too easy for him
it was kind of trippy stage two eater
right
so these again
have a comparison but now we're we're
not going to tell you what the two are
it's just one's a fart one isn't and
you'll just have to kind of judge
based off of the wavelength so okay
scroll up a little bit more
even a hair more so it's like near the
top of the page okay perfect there so we
don't get
we don't get any clues okay yeah so i
mean one is a fart and one is something
else so
okay
well go ahead zach you go first
well again it depends on the type of
fart
i'm gonna go with a on this one as the
fart as the fart that's so that's a
silent but deadly right there yes it's
very it's very flat looking mm-hmm
it could be like
yeah it'd have to be it's there's a lot
of there's it's it's very leveled out i
mean b could easily be a fart though too
right
but then again what kind of i'd be a
real ripper yeah
no not necessarily that's a fat wave
form yeah but they they get mics right
up on that i mean i mean it could be
that's true that's true
you got a good point there
um eight
i feel like it's probably gonna be a
just based on you know
ian's trying to make this challenging
for us
getting in i'm doing getting an ian's
head a little bit here interesting
actually
cameron put these together oh cam did
this cam grams interesting kim greens
ken grant's on instagram cam grant
yeah there would be a silent but deadly
in there
but then again are we going for comical
farts here
i mean uh who i mean f the comedy is in
the eye they'll boulder the nose of the
sniffer
i'm i'm gonna go a
you know did you change your answer no
i've always stuck to a okay i'm gonna go
with za i'm gonna agree with zach and go
a is the fart this time okay
hey it is here's a
take a listen
nice
wow louder than i expected
and the other one
just for posterity's sake oh no no no no
no
okay all right we're improving over time
zanka's gotten the last two exactly good
let's keep it rolling uh to round five
here so same thing you got two i'm not
gonna tell you what the uh what the two
of them are
[Music]
okay
these are tough because the wave
forms are fairly similar there they are
yeah this one has a little b has more of
a peak and valley
type vibe to it
see that very astute
good observation
but then again a
and again a i mean you gotta look at a
we need a fart timer on this
i'm gonna go a
okay a is the fart according to zach
ethan do you concur
a definitely could be a fart
b
could also be a fart quite easily
this is a tough one
you know ah
it's a tough one man i need your final
answer
uh i'm gonna go i'm gonna um i'm gonna
um
i'm gonna divert i'm gonna go b on this
one with for the fart
zach saying a ethan is saying b here is
a
ah
[ __ ] is that once again here and here's
b tricky
dude i am i am uh i haven't missed all
right he's five for five i have an
insane fart dar now there are
four more
i guess zach could still take it back if
if ethan starts missing a lot in in the
back half of these but
but you got you got some ground to make
up here so let's let's keep it rolling
the six this is the final of the
intermediates right here
uh
six yes
go ahead zacky
this if if it was a
then it looks like
it starts out loud and then kind of
leveled down
it's a burster yeah
which it could be
right
right exactly
i think i'm gonna go a again
does that go with a okay so
um here's the thing
that
the sound difference between the peak
and the value of a is concerning me
because it'd have to be like let me
think it'd have to be like
right which it could be start out real
strong
it's like one of those question mark
farts
but then you've got your use down here
in b
that's a chunky one you could tell
that's a loud fart
i'm i'm guessing it could be a but
something is just telling me it's it's
on it's unlikely because
of how tapered off it is
right although they could be throwing a
curveball yeah that's also my concern
i'm gonna go ahead and say
i'm gonna go with you zach and say a is
the fart on this one okay okay here we
go here's a
the [ __ ] i'm sorry that's a dog barking
i should have stopped my intuition let's
take a listen to b [ __ ]
i was
i was you were on the right track i was
thinking it would be a b but if it felt
like too obvious right i agree
[ __ ] well that was ethan's first miss
all right so these this is the challenge
round this is very difficult whoa these
are these are identical they're
identical because it's in stereo now
here's the thing you don't have any
comparison it's a simple
yes or no is it a fart or is it not this
is putting the money where the noses
we're not getting mono farts up in here
yeah no these are weak you know these
are
one full stereo
all right go ahead zach this is uh so
it's a fart or not a fart yep very
simple to be fart or not to fart yep
okay too far or not so what do you think
round seven farter no
what do you think ethan don't ask me
you're the big
shot i'm clearly not i'm sucking [ __ ]
right now
you're sucking ass literally literally
i'm gonna say seven is not a fart
he's saying no zack
[Music]
i'm gonna say it is
okay here we go
round seven
let's take a listen
oh all right
whoa strong one wait wait are you
repeating it or is that the same i'm
repeating it okay it's a flutter dude
it's a flutter it's a flutter which is
why you know you have that kind of
rhythm to it all righty
so okay that was the first one zach took
that away what's the score then uh so
you've missed that was around seven
you've missed two so it's five
to three i believe
really yeah
wow
so uh number eight what you guys got
there's two more
well
that could tie it up theoretically yeah
theoretically i see that's that's scary
thought that's so toughy right here dude
that's a tough feat
okay you know what
i'm gonna say no
zack says no
although
you know if i wanted to win i would just
give the same answer to zach every time
that would be impossible
yeah that's true
um but speak from your heart speaking
yeah no i will part
i'm going to say no
all right is that going to know
the question my friends is is first of
all there's game strategy would cameron
put two farts in a row that's what i'm
thinking would he put three farts in a
row the truth of the matter is it could
easily be a fart uh they
not to i mean this is a sound
uh line of reasoning but these were
somewhat randomized within the the
rounds so i wouldn't count on like you
know okay
typical game theory here okay so i'm
gonna say the last time there was a deep
tapering off it was not a fart
therefore i'm gonna once again uh say
this is not a fart you're both saying no
fart
yeah all right let's take a listen
puerto rico yeah i knew it looked
familiar puerto rico
we love play similar to a fart but uh
from the mouth
word vomit
all right so you both got that right
this is the last one it i don't think
that zach can catch you up at this point
but that's okay you're you're a warrior
though you fought your heart out yeah
it's all good you are aware my heart out
that's right so last round is it or is
it not
a fart
i'm gonna go ahead and say fart on this
one say yes yeah it's a nice clean
uh wave
wave right there my dudes
zach's in the lab he's calculating
he's got i say no
say no fart i said i say it's okay so
yes no fart that's a fart all right
here we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry but ethan apparently is the
farthest he's the real
he's the farthest well you know i'm
really happy that i learned that today
and maybe someone wants to challenge me
for my title i feel like i found
something i'm really good at yeah no i
mean you were spotting those you just
found those real good congratulations
thank you zach thank you so much you're
you're a valiant competitor a true
competitor a warrior you have a
warrior's heart and uh you fought you
fought to the bitter end thank you to
the stinky and michael thank you thank
you thank you it's a beautiful thing
yeah well
how long we've been going dana we've
been going two hours 41 minutes and 42
seconds i guess i should wrap it up for
hill doggo
hildago
so we're gonna have to continue this
clickbait conversation
you guys will see where it lands
but uh i had a lot of fun here with you
boys
thank you that was a good one that was a
good one
um
so we will be back well today's tuesday
which means oh tomorrow we're recording
a special
special episode
pretty excited oh yeah very excited
something we've been working on for a
while
something a lot of people have been
requesting
let's just put it this way
here we go
i might be getting my white powder out
okay that's fine it's fine
because i'm about to powder this wig up
because it's content core
well since we announced it
also a special shout out to the discord
huge group investigation happened on the
discord yes with ab at the helm
uh we have got a hell of a show planned
so that's gonna be tomorrow
coming out on thursday uh tomorrow for
members
yes sir and uh i'm excited
the topic is a spicy hat
okay well we got a lot of work to do
guys i hope you enjoyed uh have a
fantastic week i hope you already will
see you um
very soon
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
well i'm always triggered i'm triggered
right now like a hole
[Music]
it was meant to be for us to meet